3, 2, 1...
Entschuldigung, Zukunftszentrik, du hast dich bestimmt gerade erschrocken.
Mit einem krassen Countdown.
So, das ist witzig übrigens.
Die Mikrowell-Leute haben uns sowohl als Chapter-Mark als auch im Text gehabt
und beide Male unterschiedlich falsch geschrieben.
Und hat halt kein Mal geschrieben.
Und verkackt bei der Aussprache.
Ach Leute.
Akronomisierbar.
Ja, aber gut, den Namen können wir selber nicht mal richtig aussprechen.
Mittlerweile geht es. Ich kann es auch mittlerweile tippen.
Glaube ich.
Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar, Folge 7.
Live aus dem Internet.
Boah, sind wir live?
Heute mit Kian,
Hendrik
und, wer bist du eigentlich?
Ich bin Jupp.
Hi Jupp.
Hi.
Heute mit Jupp, Longtime Friend of the Show.
Ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt noch Christoph einladen,
dann ist jeder, der uns hört, auch schon mal in der Sendung gewesen.
Nicht jeder.
Nee, wir haben mehr Hörer, als du denkst.
Wir sind bei mehr als 10 Leuten auf jeden Fall angekommen.
Echt?
Ja.
Wir haben wieder unseren ersten Hater.
Unseren Hater, der kritisiert hat,
dass wir zu selten Folgen aufnehmen.
Stimmt, wer war das nochmal?
Manu. Hi Manu.
Hi Manu.
Der einfach gesagt hat, ihr habt zu viele Likes,
ihr braucht mehr Hater.
Ich bin jetzt offiziell euer Hater.
Sehr gut.
Ja, heute wieder erstaunlich unvorbereitet.
Wir haben so ein bisschen
ein paar GitHub-Stars vorbereitet, oder?
Ein bisschen was, Kleinigkeiten?
Ja, jeder könnte bestimmt
so spontan was vorweisen.
Und was sonst so passiert ist in der Welt?
Was ist denn jetzt passiert? Wir haben jetzt bestimmt
wieder einen Monat nicht aufgenommen, oder?
Ja, und das Größte, was passiert ist, war glaube ich
vor zwei Tagen, als die Deutsche Bahn
da so ein Problem hatte.
Wir haben doch letztes Mal schon über die Bahn geredet, oder?
Ja, aber da war es ja noch witzig.
also im Sinne von Ransomware-Angriff und ungesicherte Windows-Systeme.
Und diesmal war es ja Brandanschläge auf Anlagen der Deutschen Bahn
als Protest gegen Gipfeltreffen.
Und ich habe das erst mal gar nicht mitbekommen,
bis ich dann merkte, dass den ganzen Tag lang ich überhaupt kein Handynetz hatte.
Ich mit dem Vodafone-Netz hänge, nicht direkt Gründer bei Vodafone,
aber mit dem Vodafone-Netz über eins in eins.
Und die haben, wie ich später herausgefunden habe,
waren das einzige Netzbetreiber betroffen, so wie es ist schon davon,
weil sie ihre Handy-Masten, zumindest die Verkabelung,
alles mit in Nähe der Schienenanlagen mit inbauen.
Und so sind dann ihre Kabel mit weggepult.
Das ist eigentlich relativ naheliegend, da seine Kabel langzulegen.
Nein, ich könnte neben jeder Bahnlinie so ein fetter Kabelstrang
und allem möglichen Zeug nehmen.
Klingt doch echt logisch, muss ich sagen.
Man geht ja auch nicht davon aus, dass solche Anlagen abfackeln.
Da kann man ja nicht von ausgehen.
Ja, dann kommt der Bahn, dann brandt man und dann plötzlich ist alles offen.
Ganz schlimm
So gut, reden wir mal weiter
Wir haben also heute einen Gast, das ist der Jupp
Der Jupp hat sich vorhin spontan bereit erklärt
uns ein paar Themen zu sponsern, weil uns leider nichts eingefallen ist
Kennt ihr euch beide eigentlich überhaupt?
Ne, ich glaube nicht
Also ich kenne dich vom Namen her
Hendrik hat viel schon über dich erzählt
Ich kenne dich vom Hören her, du machst so einen Podcast, oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon, manchmal
Cool, ne, freu mich, dass dann
Genau, ich bin so ein
Kollege von dem Hendrik
und ich schreibe relativ viel Zip-Dus-Dus
und ich habe gehört,
du möchtest mal über Zip-Dus-Dus reden.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das so ein gutes On-Air-Thema ist.
Also definitiv eine Sprache,
die wir noch nicht so sehr beleuchtet haben.
Nee, das stimmt.
Ihr wart gestern beide nicht
bei der Rust-User-Group.
Das tut mir sehr leid.
Es war aber eigentlich
auch gar nicht so schlimm für euch beide.
Ich habe nämlich
eine sehr ausgiebige Anfängereinführung gegeben.
Wir sind jetzt auf Meetup
und Leute finden uns tatsächlich
allein aufgrund der Tatsache, dass wir auf Meetup sind.
Die schauen auf Meetup, sehen
Empfehlungen, haben uns empfohlen bekommen.
Du kriegst auch direkt irgendwie Mails oder Notifications
für das hier ist übrigens neu in Dresden.
Du bist doch Dresden, dann willst du nicht dahin gehen, weil das
in Dresden ist. Übrigens ist es
in Dresden. Genau, ich kriege
ganz viele seltsame Mails
von Meetup. Vor allen Dingen auch nicht wirklich
relevante, sowas wie
willst du nicht zu
Bonsai, willst du nicht zu den
Bonsai-Gärtnern nach Chemnitz
kommen, dir gibt es jetzt ein neues Meetup.
Ja, die kennen ja nicht dein Interessen.
Was aber auch gut ist.
Da kann man doch mal ein bisschen aus seiner Filter mit raus.
Oder liegt das einfach daran, dass es bis jetzt erst
fünf Meetups in Dresden gibt?
Eins davon waren die Bonsai-Gärten
in Chemnitz. Es gibt wirklich erstaunlich viele
Meetups.
Der eine, der da war, hat zum Beispiel erzählt, dass er
vorher bei dem Scala-Meetup war
und fand Meetups in Co.
Er hat sich beim Meetup angemeldet.
Dann darüber hat er uns gefunden.
Ist doch nice.
Schönen Gruß übrigens an Henrik, der
bei Mozilla arbeitet und
diesen Meetup-Account gesponsert hat.
Achso, das kostet ja jetzt was. Das kostet Geld.
Deshalb sind die Coco Heiz Dresden
Leiter von Meetup runter und wir
müssen das jetzt alles über Facebook organisieren.
Absolut schrecklich.
Da müsste man mal was programmieren.
Ich meine, so hat Meetup ja auch angefangen.
Was müssen wir machen irgendwann, wenn du eine Plattform hostest,
dann musst du irgendwann Geld verlangen. Das ist halt blöd.
Aber deswegen gibt es da längeren Versuche,
eine Coco Heiz App zu schreiben, die komplett
selbstständig läuft.
Das wird wohl nicht gehen. Es sei denn, du schreibst irgendwie so
so ein billiges, also
performance-mäßig
unaufwendiges Frontend zu irgendwas
anderem zu Facebook.
Du kannst ja zumindest auf Apple-Infrastruktur
aufbauen und dann
kein eigenes Backend haben
und das kriegst du komplett kostenlos.
Das ist quasi wie Parse, das was Parse mal war,
heißt CloudKit,
liegt auf Apple-Servern,
kriegst du quasi gehostete Datenbank
und Kram mit,
die Free-Tiers sind schon recht ergiebig,
da kannst du viel machen.
Was baut man damit? An die Web-Anwendungen?
Du kannst mittlerweile auch Web-Anwendungen bauen, die damit sprechen.
Früher war es nur iOS, jetzt ist es
und iOS.
Das ist doch mal eben für deine
iOS-Anwendung, die du bastelst, so ein kleines Web-Anwendungs.
Genau, du kannst quasi
einen Host,
einen Backend in der Cloud,
das du nicht selbst betreiben musst,
sehr wegabstrahiert von
eigenem Server-Management.
Und das läuft und das kann man nutzen.
Und da schreibt man dann JavaScript.
Man schreibt quasi, glaube ich, gar nicht mal wirklich viel
an Code, weil
man schmeißt eigentlich wirklich bloß Models rein
und die werden dann in der Datenbank
da...
So ein bisschen wie Firebase quasi.
Ja, nicht so mächtig wie Firebase, aber die Idee ist ja sehr ähnlich.
Jetzt haben wir glaube ich genügend
Competitors genannt, dass wir nicht dastehen,
als würden wir Werbung für einen Anbieter machen.
Pass gibt es ja nicht mal mehr.
Pass gibt es ja nicht mal mehr. Deine Competitor ist ja schon längst weg.
Okay,
dann müssen wir uns unbedingt noch einen nennen.
Wer macht denn noch sowas?
Das ist doch egal.
Man könnte sowas über GitHub basteln.
Machst du eine Organisation auf, das ist frei,
machst du einen Viki, dann schreibst du dir gegenseitig
ich hier es und mentions dich.
Ich dachte, du bist einfach nur Hypo-basiert.
Hypo-basiert. Wenn du ein neues Meetup machst,
musst du einen Pull-Request aufmachen oder sowas.
Das ist halt automatisch.
Beim ersten Blotch-Conflikt geht die ganze Zeit kaputt.
Bei GitHub hat es jetzt eine ganze Menge verändert, kann das sein?
Die haben irgendwie ihr Color-Scheme aufgemöbelt.
Da ist jetzt Lila mit dabei.
Gott, schrecklich.
Und man kann Pull-Requests reviewen.
Man kann irgendwie so ein Review anfangen.
Das ist aber schon länger dabei, oder?
Ja? Also mindestens ein halbes
Jahr oder ich gucke auch.
Das sollte vielleicht die ganzen Pull-Requests, die mir Leute schicken,
mal in den Bewonern langsam.
Sie bauen da relativ viel an kleinen Videos an.
Ich habe ja mal in einem Blogpost gelesen,
die deployen so 60 Mal
am Tag haufenweise
kleinen Updates. Nur wieder sieben Mal. Oh, der Button da ist
weg. Jetzt ist bei Repos plötzlich oben dieser
Graphs-Button verschwunden, den Insights-Tab.
Hoffenweise so Klein-Scheiß.
Bei Insights gibt es jetzt auch einen Community-Unterpunkt
sogar. Da kannst du
irgendwie deinen Code of Conduct und deine Lizenz
Also nicht nur deine Lizenz aus einem Template zusammenklicken,
sondern auch Code of Conduct zusammenklicken.
Cool, fällt mir.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Aber wenn die sagen, dass die 60 Mal am Tag deployen,
das heißt nicht, dass die alle 24 Minuten
irgendwie ihre komplette Anwendung neu aufzimmern,
sondern dass die wahrscheinlich 60 Mal am Tag
unterschiedliche Mengen von Nutzern,
eine unterschiedliche Version von GitHub zur Verfügung stellen.
Oder die werden doch nicht alle auf einmal
auf eine neue Version aufhalten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das verbreitet.
Achso, übrigens geht draußen gerade die Welt unter.
Ich habe mir gerade so ein bisschen
geflackert.
Wie ist das denn?
Genau.
Wir sind vom Büro aus mit dem Fahrrad los.
Zwischendurch haben wir uns irgendwo untergestellt.
Oh, jetzt donnert es.
Das ist die Weltart.
Wir haben uns irgendwo untergestellt.
Da habe ich Jupp meinen Laptop in seine
wasserdichtere Fahrradtasche getan.
Dann sind wir nach Hause.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich bin nach Hause,
habe mich komplett umgezogen und bin jetzt die letzten 100 Meter
im Auto gefahren.
Wenn ich dich noch mitnehmen soll,
dann sag Bescheid.
Wenn du den Riesing-Umweg
nachher verantwortest.
Genau, mein Fahrrad steht jetzt hier neben dem Podcast-Tisch
und da sind so
quasi fast alle meine Sachen
drüber gebreitet und das dient als
Wäscheständer.
Ich sitze hier übrigens gerade nackt am Tisch.
Für die
weiblichen Zuhörer draußen.
Für unsere weiblichen Hörer.
Gibt es eigentlich weibliche Hörer
von Akronomisierma?
wir wissen, also wir kennen
jetzt glaube ich alle eigentlich persönlich.
Ich glaube ja, ich kenne eine Hörerin,
die ab und zu mal sagt,
die Folge war mir zu technisch oder die Folge
war witzig.
Es ist schon wieder so, als ob uns keine Frauen hören, die technisches
Grundverständnis sind.
Manchmal,
wenn ich muss zugehen bei der einen Folge, wo
Steiger dabei war, dann bin ich auch mal kurz ausgesownt
bei irgendeinem Thema.
Steiger macht aber auch abgefahrenen Kram.
Und wenn er dann so richtig reinspringt, dann
wird es halt krass.
Hallo Steiger.
Schönen Gruß an Steiger.
Das ist cool gerade.
Worüber wollen wir als erstes reden?
Du hast hier in deine Liste Zeugs reingeschrieben
wie WWDC.
Fährst du da wieder hin?
Die war jetzt vor zwei Wochen.
Drei Wochen.
So uninformiert bin ich.
Irgendwie Anfang Juni.
Letztes Jahr war ich da.
War sehr, sehr spaßig.
Dieses Jahr leider nicht.
Ich habe mich auch gar nicht beworben
für so ein Scholarship,
aber es wäre cool gewesen.
Vor allem, weil die umgezogen ist.
Das ist auch nicht der Apple-Podcast,
der jetzt einen Stunden lang über die
DabDab reden muss, aber es sind
ein paar coole Sachen gezeigt worden.
Also die WWDC ist ja generell eher
die Entwicklerorientierte
Konferenz. Nicht, dass
wir neue Konsumprodukte
an Mass, sondern
das sind neue Betriebssysteme,
diese APIs gibt es jetzt,
das sind neue coole Dinge, die wir generell haben.
Übrigens, das ist unsere neue Programmiersprache.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren der Fall, genau.
Was besonders cool
meiner Meinung nach das Announcement von Swift 4.
Aber da war jetzt ja nicht
viel Unbekanntes dabei, weil Swift ist ja
mittlerweile auch Open Source seit
mehr als einem Jahr, drei Jahren, glaube ich.
Das heißt, die Leute wissen schon, was da läuft.
Vieles ist bekannt. Nicht jeder liest auch wirklich
alles mit auf der Mailing-Liste.
Immer noch nicht von der Mailing-Liste weg?
Nein, wir sind nicht weg von der Mailing-Liste. Sehr langweilig.
Es gibt einen Diskurs,
das immer noch festweise betrieben wird.
Mehr als einmal
das komplette Archiv der Mailing-Liste importiert
ins Diskurs.
Das ist jetzt das Problem, es soll ja nichts abhanden kommen
an alle Diskussionen.
Mailing-Listen Archive in den Diskurs importieren,
das wäre was, wofür ich mich auch mal interessieren würde.
Ich glaube, das ist selbst geschrieben.
Das ist bestimmt dann in Swift geschrieben.
Vielleicht, wer weiß.
Aber es gab ein paar coole Sachen
und eine Sache, die ganz am Rande am Ende genannt wurde,
die ich aber sehr cool fand, eine Sache, die du vielleicht auch cool findest,
das hat sich so still und heimlich reingeschlichen,
da habe ich überhaupt nichts vorher gelesen,
auf Mailing-Listen,
ist, dass Swift 4 jetzt eine Art
interessantes neues Ownership-Model hat,
zumindest teilweise,
und so kann der Compiler tatsächlich
dir jetzt einen Error hinwerfen,
wenn du Mutual Access auf irgendwas hast
und versuchst, an einer anderen Stelle im gleichen
Kontext auch noch weiter zu mutieren.
Dann sagt er direkt zur Compiler-Zeit,
nö, nö, nö, stopp, das geht so nicht, das lasse ich
nicht zu. Oder wenn er es nicht
ganz ausschließen kann, zum Beispiel wenn es um Reference-Types
geht, weil da soll jetzt aber nicht
massiv Overhead mit rein, so wie es es verstanden hat,
aber wenn er halt vermutet, dass da was
geht, dann läuft das zur Runtime,
aber du einen Debug willst und dann kommt da der
Error. Aber ich finde das
trotzdem eine sehr willkommene Sache.
Die Inspiration mit anderen Sprachen läuft
weiter, so wie es scheint.
Das ist nett. Mehr Rusty Features und generell
mehr Sachen, die Sicherheit zur Compile
Zeit geben, immer rein damit.
Finde ich sehr begrüßenswert.
Auf jeden Fall.
Bei C++ gibt es ja auch schon Ansätze dazu,
oder? Ownership und
Modelle einzuführen, oder?
Naja, also
Generell sollte man das bei C++ sowieso machen,
wenn man programmiert,
dass man sich um sowas Gedanken macht.
Aber es gibt kein statisches Enforcement dafür bislang.
Es gibt diese C++ Core Guidelines,
die von Microsoft vor ein paar Jahren
mittlerweile schon entwickelt wurden.
Und dafür gibt es jetzt auch statische Tools,
die das checken.
Also dieses Kling Static Analyzer Projekt,
Klang, das
hat da schon Support, um das auch
in SeptuSbus quasi zu checken.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie viel davon
schon funktioniert oder wie viele
False Negatives
das da gibt.
Ich weiß zumindest,
dass man für solche Sachen wie Ownership
dann
in der Sprache relativ umständlich
Sachen drumherum schreiben muss. Du hast irgendwie
einen Ownership Rapper,
einen Borrow Rapper
um bestimmte Variablen, um Pointer drum herum,
dass du was nur geowned annehmen kannst
oder was nur als geborrowed annehmen kannst.
Das heißt, ich schreibe es dann explizit rein,
ich nehme hier eine geborrowed Referenz
für irgendwas ein. Das ist halt kein Teil der Sprache,
weil die Sprache halt schon fertig ist.
Genau, also du hast ja
bei C++
in der Standard-Library
ein paar unterschiedliche Arten von Pointern.
Du hast
Shared-Pointer, das sind Pointer,
die Shared-Ownership haben,
Also da können an mehreren Stellen Objekte die Speicher ohne.
Du hast jetzt nach C++11 die Unique Pointer.
Da kann immer nur einer den ownen.
Und wenn man es transferieren will, die Ownership,
dann kann man das moveen.
Also Movesimantik sind auch neu.
Und da gibt es halt noch so Auto-Pointer.
Das ist jetzt Diplicated.
Das sollte man eigentlich nicht mehr nehmen.
In ein paar Libraries gibt es auch noch
solche Sachen wie
Owning-Pointer, wo man das gar nicht
transferieren kann.
Die kann man einfach nicht kopieren.
Genau, die kann man einfach nicht kopieren und auch nicht
muben.
Krass. Um nochmal
auf
Swift zurückzukommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt, aber der Chris Lettner,
der
LVM-Erfinder,
also das war seine
Masterarbeit,
Der hat ja lange Zeit bei Apple gearbeitet
und auch Swift maßgeblich miterfunden.
Und der wurde ja vor kurzem von Tesla abgeworben.
Er hat zumindest selbstständig immer weiß ich.
Also wie es genau gelaufen ist, weiß man nicht.
Aber er hat auf jeden Fall bei Tesla angefangen zu arbeiten
und hat jetzt aber irgendwie letzte Woche auf Twitter geschrieben,
dass doch kein guter Fit ist und dass er sich jetzt was anderes tut.
Das ist sehr spannend.
Was aber auch sehr krass ist, ist jetzt auch mal auf seiner Seite, glaube ich.
Genau, seiner Seite sein Resümee.
wenn man da durchlegt, was er bei Tesla
alles gemacht hat in dem halben Jahr, wo er da war
die haben ja komplett
ihren Autopilot neu geschrieben
und er hat diese zweite Version
richtig stark mit vorangetrieben, also für ein halbes
Jahr in Arbeit ist das beeindruckend
was da passiert ist
den Link mal mit in die Show Notes mit rein
haben
das lässt sich echt gut euten
mal schauen, was er jetzt macht, hoffentlich
jetzt zu Facebook oder so
ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass Apple sagt
Magst du nicht doch wieder zu uns zurückkommen?
Wir ein bisschen was da machen.
Naja, ich meine, er wird sicherlich seine Kunde haben,
warum er gegangen ist mit seinen eigenen Challenges.
Er wird wahrscheinlich nicht zurückgehen,
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
dass er mindestens ein Anbot nochmal kriegen könnte.
Ich hoffe mal, er macht jedenfalls die gute Arbeit bei Alien weiter,
weil es ist halt schon ein echt tolles Projekt.
Das hat er aber auch nicht aufgegeben.
Und auch bei Swift ist er noch mit.
Da ist nach wie vor drin,
er verschafft auf der Mailing-Liste,
Merge-Dinge,
er implementiert auch teilweise Videos.
nicht sehr cool.
Aber spannender Typ auf jeden Fall, was der so macht.
Der hat angefangen mit LLVM?
Genau, war seine
Masterarbeit und der hat angefangen, das zu implementieren.
Aber der hat doch,
hat der nicht sogar einen PhD?
Ja, bestimmt.
Weiß nicht.
Er hat einen PhD
über die Thesis
Macroscopic Data Structure Analysis
and Optimization 2005
an der
an der University of Illinois.
Genau.
Lese ich auch gerade aus,
das ist eine längere Art,
die mir sagt.
Okay, spannende Leute haben eine spannende Karriere.
Okay.
Was ich auch ziemlich cool fand auf der
WWDC,
war, dass es
jetzt endlich NFC gibt
auf Apple,
auf der Mobilplattform, also
Core-NFC, zumindest als Library.
das habe ich auch lange vermisst
also ich habe auch so ein
Apple-Telefon
Was für einst du dran?
Ich habe ein iPhone 6 Plus
Dann hast du keinen NFC-Zugang?
Dann habe ich auch noch keinen NFC-Zugang, nee, aber
dass sie es überhaupt mal öffnen
finde ich zumindest positiv
Finde ich auch sehr schön, ich wollte schon immer
mal diese tolle Mensa-Guthaben-App
die es für Android gibt, mal auf iOS
implementieren
Also du hast glaube ich seit dem iPhone
6 NFC-Hardware drin,
die wurde aber nur intern genutzt für
Apple Pay und ab dem
iPhone 7 und iOS 11 hast du
die Möglichkeit, ein sehr kleines
Subset von NFC tatsächlich mit,
also du kannst NFC-Tags lesen.
Du kannst nichts Schreibendes machen mit den APIs aktuell,
das heißt, du kannst keine Karte emulieren,
aber du kannst Tags
lesen. Aber da gibt es
ja auch, NFC ist ja unheimlich
kompliziert, habe ich mir letztens mal ein bisschen erklären lassen,
dass es ja auch die ganzen Standards, die es da gibt,
von über MyFair,
alleine, die die verbreitetsten Karten
mit haben, da muss man ja teilweise Daten
auf die Karte schreiben, bevor man Daten
lesen kann. Das geht dann zum Teil auch
nicht. Das ist unglaublich
weird.
Aber allgemein habe ich
den Eindruck, Apple sieht jetzt so ein paar Features nach
im Jahr 2017, die sie eigentlich auch schon
vor drei, vier Jahren haben. Das hört man zu jeder
Adapter. Jedes Mal, wenn iOS angekündigt wird,
ja, alles klar. Und die Features von Android, das ist doch
in beide Richtung. Safari ist jetzt
WebRTC drin. Ja, auch
Desktop, endlich. Das heißt, wir
endlich über Palawa TV
mit du mit deinem Safari,
mit ich mit meinem Firefox springen.
Stimmt, Palawa war immer so ein schönes Beispiel.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Warum ich eigentlich heiß darauf bin,
dass es unter iOS
NFC gibt, ist,
ich bin so ein User von so einem
YubiKey.
So ein CryptoKey,
der dir eine Smartcard emuliert.
Und womit man
sowas machen kann,
wie,
also wofür ich es größtenteils benutze,
ist, meine SSH-Keys sind da drauf,
beziehungsweise GPG-Keys sind drauf,
aus denen SSH-Keys derived werden.
Und was daran ziemlich cool ist,
ist, wenn du so ein Angriffsszenario hast,
wie jemand hackt deinen Rechner
oder irgendwie Malware oder sowas,
schützt sich das davor,
dass der Angreifer dein SSH-Key klaut.
Weil der SSH-Key wird da drauf generiert auf dem Gerät.
Also man muss sich das so vorstellen,
wie so ein kleiner Stick,
der genauso groß ist wie ein USB-Port.
Die gibt es auch ein bisschen größer mit NFC-Support fürs Telefon.
Und darauf wird der Key generiert.
Und wenn du dich mit SSH auf irgendeinen Server connectest,
dann sendet der Server so eine Challenge an deinen SSH-Client.
Und den gibt es der dann weiter an die Smartcard.
Und die beantwortet ihn dann.
Und der Private Key hat quasi nie den Hauptspeicher irgendeines Computers gesehen.
Deswegen kann man den nicht klauen.
man muss draufdrücken, damit das beantwortet wird, physisch.
Also wenn ein Angreifer deinen Rechner
hackt, dann kann er dir nicht
deine Keys klauen und deine ganzen Server aufmachen.
Bis du
diesen Key verlierst.
Bis du diesen Key verlierst, dann ist es halt weg.
Das heißt, man holt sich immer zwei davon,
richtet beide ein und
versteckt einen, weiß ich, in der Wohnung?
Ja, oder du generierst
dir halt noch einen auf einem
sicheren Gerät,
den du dann in den Schrank legst,
auf einen Storage-Device oder irgendwie in irgendein
sicheres, in einen sicheren Ort
für den Fall, dass sowas passiert, ja.
Klingt cool.
Und der Use-Case für das Mobile-Device
ist dann, du
hältst quasi deinen NFC-Tag
dann an dein Gerät ran und
man die Chat-Beautomation. Also die haben noch mehr,
die haben noch mehr Features.
Eins davon ist,
dass es als Two-Factor-Authentication
Gerät dient.
Da gibt es so einen Standard, der heißt
U2F.
Universal Two-Factor
und da kann man
sich bei GitHub und Google
und einigen anderen, die das supporten,
so ein Device registrieren
und dann drückt man einfach im Browser
drauf und das ist nochmal ein bisschen
sicherer, als wenn man
jetzt irgendwie ein
auf ein Mobilgerät das hat.
Also ich lockere mich auf die Art und Weise bei GitHub
und bei meinem Mailprovider an.
Okay.
Tool Factor nutze ich klassisch im Sinne von
ich habe ein extra
so klassisch
muss ja in meinem Fall ein bisschen besonders
weil es dasselbe Gerät sein kann, ein bisschen weird
aber ich habe halt
irgendwas anderes, was noch
den extra Code generieren muss, damit das halt geht
aber es ist selten
extra Hardware, was sich ein bisschen
tot umführt. Wir haben zum Beispiel
müssen uns auf Arbeit
auch über Tool Factor einloggen
da hast du halt eine App auf dem Handy
und es gibt so ein, zwei Kollegen, die ich jetzt nicht namentlich
nennen möchte, die irgendwie keine Lust haben,
sich extra
dafür ein Smartphone anzuschaffen, weil sie auch keins haben,
die sich dann auf ihrem Laptop einfach
so den Android-Emulator installieren
und sich dann darüber einloggen.
Auch nett.
Ich finde es auch nicht so wirklich sinnvoll, irgendwie
auf einer Mobile-Plattform,
die
ja im Prinzip auch nicht so super sicher sind,
also da ist vielleicht Android noch eher als
iOS, dass es irgendwie keine
Patches gibt oder dass die Leute nicht rechtzeitig patchen
und es ist halt doch ganz schön viel Mailware gibt,
dass man das dann
umgedingt nimmt.
Ja, es ist halt
Ticks sinnvoller, Ticks sicherer
als nur Passwort, aber
es ist halt nicht
super sicher auf jeden Fall.
Diese RSA-Secure-ID-Dinge,
wo man immer wieder so ein witziges
Web findet, irgendwo unter
random IP-Adresse
zum Internet offener Webcam-Stream,
der auch so ein Ding zeigt.
Das ist immer großartig.
Du kannst immer noch Security by Obscurity machen.
Du stellst 10x10 davon aus,
filmst die alle ab,
dann ist das Geheimnis im Prinzip, welche Reihe und welche Zeile.
Shit.
Passwörter sind schwierig.
Und Authentication ist ein sehr komplexes Problem.
Ich habe auch so einen YubiKey.
Ich habe den mit NFC.
Und der einzige Use Case, den ich für NFC
bislang irgendwie gefunden habe, ist, dass ich damit
mein Handy entsperren kann.
Ich habe es allerdings nur fünf Minuten genutzt,
bis mir dann eingeleuchtet ist,
dass das eigentlich eine schlechte Idee ist,
das zu machen.
Weil dann halt jeder, der mein Telefon hat
und meinen Schlüssel hat, damit auch mein Telefon entsperren kann.
Bisschen sinnlos.
Aber
schön wäre es, wenn man richtig
paranoid ist,
wenn man damit seine Two-Factor-Authentication-App,
die man auf dem Telefon hat, entsperrt.
über NFC. Dann hast du quasi,
du musst das Telefon haben, du musst den Schlüssel
haben und dann kannst du dich erst mit dem Passwort
dann bei einer Webseite einbauen.
Und dann wird
deine HTTPS-Verbindung mitgesnifft.
Hast du auch nichts
gefunden. Blöd.
Ja, aber ein bisschen
abseits von dem Thema, der
Two-Factor-Authentication oder YubiKey oder was auch
immer für extra Geräte.
Authentication ist ja schön breit gefächert
und da gibt es ja diverse witzige Ansätze.
weg von komischen Biometrie-Dingen,
die jetzt immer populärer werden, wie
Fingerabdrücke oder Iris-Scans
waren es, glaube ich, in den neuen Samsung-Geräten, die da
jetzt konsumertauglich
vertrieben werden und schon gequackt wurden.
Interessanterweise von denselben Leuten, die gerne mal
Fingerabdrücke kaputt machen.
Starbuck vom CCC.
Und ich habe da mal ein
cooles Projekt gesehen gehabt. Die hatten
eine Login-Seite, es ist Demo
und du hast ein Passwort oder ein Passphrase
eingegeben, aber das war kein Passphrase,
den du dir merken musst, sondern der stand da
über dem Feld, wo du es eingeben musst.
Und die haben dich erkannt anhand deiner Art und Weise,
wie du getippt hast.
Also welche Buchstaben, wie schnell auf welche Buchstaben gefolgt haben
und so weiter.
Und ich glaube auch, Tippfehler waren auch okay
und wurden auch teilweise genutzt,
um dich irgendwie klarzumachen, dass du du bist.
Das war echt schwierig.
Von deiner Tippweise.
Genau, von deiner Tippweise.
Es war echt schwierig, jemanden zu faken,
weil es halt klar ist.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sowas sicher sein kann.
Du musst ja auch irgendeinen Fingerprint von dem Nutzer erzeugen.
Ein Fingerprint kann Software sicherlich auch gut faken.
Bitte gib einmal, 1000 Mal dieses Passwort auf die Random Anzeigen.
Erst mal das Model anlernen, was dich dann erkennen soll.
Aber es fand ich einfach eine witzige Idee,
mal eine andere Herangehensweise.
Ja, sowas ähnliches hat ja Google schon als Capture-Ersatz.
Du musst ja mittlerweile nur noch mit der Maus
in so ein kleines Fältchen reinklicken.
Ich bin kein Roboter.
Und die erkennen anhand deiner Mausbewegung
und wie schnell du darauf reagierst.
Kommt die Fingerprinten auf dein Browser zu dem Zeitpunkt noch mit?
Ich glaube, die nehmen einfach alle Daten, die sie sowieso schon aus den letzten halben Stunden über dich haben
und schicken das in irgendein...
Fünf Gigabyte, die du in den letzten 15 Sekunden geschickt hast oder sowas.
Genau.
Das ist, glaube ich, das, was sie sowieso schon alles über dich wissen.
Obwohl ich das vorherige Recapture eigentlich viel cooler fand,
wo du diversen Google-Diensten geholfen hast, Daten zu erkennen, deren OCR oder was auch immer nicht erkannt hat.
da einfach quasi den kostenlosen
Amazon Mechanical Turk
als Dichtern mit davor geschmissen hat.
Das war so lange interessant, bis die Leute gecheckt haben,
dass sie nur das erste Wort von den beiden richtig
eingeben müssen, dass bei den zweiten gibt es da
dann irgendwie Shit oder Fuck ein, damit dann deren
Bilderkennung überall nur noch Shit und Fuck rausliest,
wenn es irgendwelche Bücher scannt.
Und bis irgendwie Leute in Indien
oder China solche Klickfarben eingeführt
haben, wo dann Leute in Szenerreihen
sitzen und den ganzen Tag so ein Zeugs machen.
Ja, auch mal irgendwann Captures
wegautomatisiert mit einem Skript, das an irgendeinen
sehr creepy Service
geschickt hat, der das dann, keine Ahnung,
für witzige Geldbeträge
sonst wo wahrscheinlich menschlich gelöst hat.
Da wollte ich Dinge runterladen
von irgendwelchen One-Click-Haus.
Es gab mal so, wie hieß denn dieses eine
Download-Tour, mit dem du von J-Downloader
J-Downloader, wo du von diversen
fischigen
von diversen fischigen Webseiten runterladen
könntest und du musstest am Anfang, wenn du das Ding
gelauncht hast, musstest du so ein Guthaben aufbauen
und zehnmal so ein Capture eingeben für andere
Leute, damit du dann
einfach weiterhin Sachen runterladen kannst
und die Captures für dich gelöst werden. Das sind dann die
Captures, die andere Leute für dich lösen.
Das war eigentlich ein witziger Ansatz.
Das kann ich auch machen.
Aber Captures sehe ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ich sehe nur noch ab und zu diese Button, ich bin kein Roboter
und das war's. Das ist ja auch ein Capture quasi.
Das ist halt
moderner.
Bei so Sachen wie
Klickgeschwindigkeit oder Tipp
Reihenfolge oder sowas, sag ich nicht immer,
Funktioniert das auch nach drei Bier noch?
Eigentlich nicht.
Wenn du sowas tunst,
hast du ja immer die Möglichkeit,
das so zu tunen, dass es möglichst
wenige Falls Positives hat oder dass es
möglichst wenige Falls Negatives hat.
Irgendwo musst du diesen Grad laufen.
Das wäre eine gute Art und Weise, du könntest diese Technologie
verwenden, um dein Auto aufzuschließen.
Erstens würde es dich als Fahrer identifizieren
und zweitens würde es dich aussperren, wenn du
drei Bier getrunken hast.
Aber vielleicht auch, wenn du erkältet bist oder dir gerade die Hand
verstaucht hast oder andere Sachen.
Es gibt ja ganz viele Sachen, wo man sich irgendwie denkt,
es könnte es ändern, wie man die Tasten tippt.
Oder wenn du drüber nachdenkst,
dass du möglichst so tippen musst, wie du sonst auch immer tippst,
dann kannst du plötzlich nicht mehr tippen.
Ich habe heute auf einer Grußkarte unterschrieben
und dachte mir, wenn ich jetzt meine Unterschrift
darauf mache, muss sie natürlich hilfreich aussehen.
Habe ich sie vorher fünfmal geübt, weil ich so selten Sachen
unterschreibe. Dann habe ich sie wieder drauf
geschrieben und sie sah komplett anders aus
als vorher. Wenn du genau drüber
nachdenkst, kannst du plötzlich nicht mehr Sachen unterschreiben.
Weil das ist, was so aus der
aus der Hüfte kommen muss quasi.
Aus der Hüfte vor.
Ja, so.
Gab es noch irgendwas anderes Cooles von der
Apple-Konferenz?
Neues iOS
hat ein paar nette Features. Ich bin
wie jedes Jahr der Depp, der direkt
die erste Beta auf sein eigenes Gerät
installiert und sich dann ärgert, dass Dinge scheiße
funktionieren. Ich habe
festgestellt, dass man WatchOS-Betas
nicht mehr von der Watch runterkriegt,
sondern um von der Watch Beta-Rockdown zu graden,
musst du das Gerät an Apple schicken.
Jetzt bleibe ich auf der Beta.
Aber deine Uhr stürzt nicht alle 10 Minuten ab, oder?
Nee, aber ich hatte einen witzigen Bug mit der ersten Beta.
Gestern kam die zweite Beta raus, jetzt ist es gefixt.
Aber mit der ersten Beta hatte ich das witzige Problem.
Das Springboard, das ist quasi der Homescreen-Service auf dem iOS,
alle 10 Sekunden crashed, wenn ich im Eduroam bin.
Und zwar nur, wenn ich im Eduroam bin.
Habe ich an verschiedenen Hochschulen tatsächlich getestet.
Klappt sehr, sehr zuverlässig.
Schatz, ich muss mal kurz nochmal
an die evangelische Hochschule gehen
und testen, ob da das Edge Room meine Uhr
auch zum Gleichen bringt.
Ja, aber es gab ja auch da mit iOS 10 Beta
gegen Edge Room ja auch nicht, aber das lag daran,
dass, also nicht nur iOS, sondern auch
macOS damals, dass Apple
längere Keys entforst hat und
da hatte die TU Dresden
nicht mitgezogen, beziehungsweise
erst zwei Tage
nach dem Release mitgezogen, als
ein gewisser Prof dem hier das
die komplette Infrastruktur
quasi gehört, in Anführungsstrichen,
seine Geräte geupdate hat und plötzlich das Internet
nicht mehr liebt.
Ich dachte, da gab es so einen Mob von Studenten
mit Fackeln und Missgaben.
Nee, leider nicht.
Ja, schlimm, wahrscheinlich hätte es auch eigentlich nichts gebracht.
Es muss erst an dieser einen Person
scheitern und erst wird es da.
Dann werden Dinge plötzlich geupdate.
Ich hatte damals die witzige kleine Webseite
istedugumnochkaputt.de
kurz gestartet, wo mit Erklärung
und Feedback vom ZDH
tatsächlich. Und ich habe auch Feedback vom ZEH
für diese Webseite bekommen.
Die gibt es nicht mehr mittlerweile. Brauchst du nicht mehr schauen.
Die sind jetzt ausgelaufen.
Das wollte ich jetzt hier so still am Rande machen.
Red ruhig weiter.
Ne, solche Sachen passieren natürlich immer.
Auf Betas ist immer etliches kaputt. Ich meine, es ist eine Beta.
Vor allem ist es nicht mal eine Public-Beta. Die kommt erst
in einer Woche raus wahrscheinlich.
Das heißt, es ist die Beta, die du installierst als Entwickler,
um zu testen, ob deine App noch läuft. Und alle
meine Apps laufen noch. Das macht mich sehr glücklich.
Dafür laufen viele Third-Party-Apps auf meinem Gerät nicht mehr.
Also teilweise nicht. Ich kann nur die Dresden-Fahnen
vor App nicht mehr nutzen, weil ich keine Haltestellen
eingeben kann. Bei YouTube kann man nichts suchen.
Also viele kleine UI-Bugs, die halt passieren, aber
das ist normal. Und als normaler
Nutzer wundert man sich, dass man plötzlich
50 geupdatete
Apps hat, die alle
irgendwie 200 Megabyte groß sind.
Weil die alle mit den
Bugs nachziehen müssen? Genau, weil die alle
schon mal ihre Apps fixen.
Das ist dann auch wirklich garantiert fertig
und durch den App Store Review Prozess gelaufen ist,
wenn es dann rauskommt. Achso, man merkt
mal so eine Welle an Updates, bevor die nächste iOS
Genau, du weißt eigentlich gar nicht, was los ist, weil es gibt ja
kein Update für dich. Aber dann
denkst du dir, ach, alles klar, jetzt ist wahrscheinlich die neue
Weta rausgekommen und dann updaten die
alle hier.
Was ist cooles
Neues in iOS?
UI-Wohn ein bisschen overhauled. Ich finde es cool,
dass die winziges kleines Feature ist,
die Kamera einen QR-Code wieder mal eingebaut hat
und vor allem jetzt auch so coole Features hat,
wie das, wo man mit Bill Party Apps und Android kann.
Man kann eine WiFi-Einrichtung über die Kamera
über QR-Code machen.
Wenn ich meinen WiFi-QR-Code habe,
noch den Routen kleben.
Das ist auch nur etwas, was Android schon seit 10 Jahren kann.
Aber nur mit der Party-Apps.
Das stimmt. Ich frage mich jedes Mal,
warum nicht in den Standard-Kamera-Apps
QR-Code-Laser eingebaut ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum in QR-Code-Scanner
nicht Zugang zu meinen
Bilddatenbanken eingebaut ist.
Weil manchmal habe ich ein Foto von einem QR-Code
und weiß nicht, wie ich das nachdenklich einscannen soll.
Und noch ein zweites Gerät.
Du kannst auch diesen herrlichen XKCD weiterzumachen.
scannen sie jetzt diesen QR-Code ein
und du kriegst das gerade auf deinem Handy dargestellt.
Was machst du da mit Konstruktion
mit vier Spiegel?
Einspiegel und die Frontkamera, oder?
Und dann kannst du das nicht lesen, weil es spiegelverkehrt ist.
Oder du musst es mit der
Hinterkamera machen.
Nee, QR-Codes
hat man gefühlt auch nur in Europa
seltenmal, sonst wo auf der Welt sind die komplett
tot, habe ich das Gefühl zumindest.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch
zu wenig gut.
Also so zum Geocachen ist gut.
Dann, wenn man halt auf irgendwelchen Plakaten
irgendwelche Sachen
scannen soll, das ist ja total langweilig.
Weil du kannst auch einfach den
kurzen, prägnanten Namen von dem Ding
googeln.
Also was ich benutzt habe,
bevor es KDE Connect gab,
war es, um mir URLs
vom Browser aufs Handy zu schicken.
Da habe ich so ein Plugin gehabt für Firefox,
da habe ich dann einfach den Link angeklickt, QR-Code,
das Handy drauf gehalten und dann konnte ich
mit dem Blogpost aufs Klo gehen
und den dortigen.
Wir haben vom Campus Navigator
dieses Projekt, was ich an der TU für iOS
mit maintaine, jetzt
das an Gebäudeschildern
QR-Calls mit drauf sind, die
humorös klein sind, sage ich mal.
Du musst wirklich bis exakt vor dieses
Schild gehen, damit du überhaupt siehst, dass
dein QR-Call ist, weil der winzig ist.
Und dann kann dein Handy wirklich
physisch an dieses Schild ran. Das ist ein bisschen
dumm, aber die Idee ist halt die, dass
du quasi vom Schild direkt in die blinken,
die App hast oder an einen Raumschilder
soll das mit ran. Klingt erstmal doof,
aber ist vor allem auch aus Barrierefreiheitsgründen
mit, dass jemand, der weiß, dass
er gerade irgendwo ist, ein Raumschild
ertasten kann, mit dem Handy abscannen und
gesagt kriegt, an welchem Raum er gerade steht
und quasi auch Indoor-Routing weitermachen kann.
Das heißt, das Raumschild ist aber auch wirklich immer genau
15 Zentimeter rechts von
der Brei-Schriftseile,
wo der Gebäudenname dran steht.
Schön wär's.
Ich habe irgendwie mit Sebastian
darüber geredet, der ist blind,
Ja, das ist total sinnlos. Ich darf jetzt als Blinder mit meinem Smartphone hier kurz hervorgehen.
Das bringt mir überhaupt nichts.
Nee, es bringt nicht viel. Aber gerade für das Indoor-Routing finde ich es eine nette Sache.
Da machen sich ja an der Uni relativ viele Projekte.
Ja, haben wir auch schon mit drin im Kameradegator.
Zumindest für ausgewählte Gebäude, weil es noch recht Beta ist.
Aber das war schon die Arbeit von Philipp Thöricht.
Genau. Ich saß sogar in der Diplomarbeit, die Diplomverteidigung mit drin.
Ich habe die gleich gesehen. Oder auch da?
Hm.
Weird.
Egal.
Du warst nicht damit dabei.
Hilft das dann, dass man sich nie wieder im Schuhmannbau fallen läuft?
Das wird niemals passieren.
Du musst aber die Augen zumachen und blind diesen Anweisungen folgen.
Also der Schuhmannbau ist wirklich so ein Gebäude aus dem Campus,
was so jeglicher Logik fern ist, wie das aufgebaut ist.
Ich musste da einmal für eine Veranstaltung in den Keller.
Ich bin in den Haupteingang rein und habe festgestellt,
nach langem, langem Suchen, dass es keine Treppe
vom Erdgeschoss in den Keller gibt.
Man muss in den ersten Stock, um in den Keller
runterzukommen. Und nach welcher Logik
geht man denn die Treppe hoch, wenn ich versuche
einen Weg nach unten zu gehen?
Ich glaube, es war ja auch mal ein Gefängnis.
Ja, mit Todestrakt.
Und da ist ja sowas vielleicht auch hilfreich.
Schön, wie du das gesagt hast.
Ich finde das immer so ein Detail,
dass es noch düsterer macht.
Wart ihr in der Ausstellung mal drin?
Ja.
Also da ist tatsächlich ein Museumsabteil, wo man Ausstellungen zu den Zeiten Nazizeit und kurz davor und kurz danach sieht
und mit Zeitzeugen, nicht mit Zeitzeugen reden kann, aber Interviews mit Zeitzeugen, das ist wirklich sehr sehenswert.
Aber ich habe es auch schon erlebt, dass ich das Übungen musste.
Und dann gehst du eine Treppe hoch, dann gehst du wieder eine Treppe runter.
Und dann gehst du durch eine Tür, wo der Name des Raums draufsteht, aber nicht ganz,
sondern das ist nicht A, sondern B, aber A hast du nicht gefunden.
Dann machst du die Tür auf, da ist direkt dahinter noch eine andere Tür.
Und dann sitzt du dich hin und dann kommen die anderen durch andere Türen in den Raum,
die du vorher noch gar nicht gesehen hast.
Dieser Raum, dieses Gebäude.
Oder du musst durch den vollen Hörsaal gehen, um in den Übungsraum zu kommen,
weil der einfach nur durch diesen vollen Hörsaal erreichbar ist.
Oh, geil.
Aber es gibt immer diesen einen Raum, da machten wir immer zur Erstsemestereinführung hier.
Das ist quasi Teil der Schnitzeljagd, weil der unglaublich blöd zu finden ist.
liegt von der Raumnummer her nicht in dem Stockwerk,
wo er eigentlich ist, sondern in so einem Halbstockwerk,
das dazwischen liegt und was man nur an einer
bestimmten Stelle von dem Gebäude gefühlt betreten
kann. Das ist total
komisch. Und dann gibt es den B-Flügel
und dieser Raum fängt mit dem B an, ist aber
nicht im B-Flügel.
Ich glaube, das war auch
der, von dem ich gerade geredet habe.
Ein rundes Fenster nach vorne.
Das ist mega komisch. Ich finde es mega verantwortungslos,
dass da Studentenpartys mit Alkohol stattfinden.
Ich möchte ja fest behaupten, dass da
diverse Leute betrunken.
Tagelang nicht wieder raus.
Man vermutet ja auch, dass irgendwie nachts noch
Geister von Studenten, die den
nicht mehr rausgefunden haben,
dass sie dann durch die Gänge...
Wo ist das 184a?
Nein.
Liebevoll übrigens
unter Studenten auch immer Hogwarts genannt.
Das habe ich schon öfter gehört.
Aber es sieht auch krass so aus.
Ist aber auch ein schönes Gebäude so von außen.
Jetzt haben wir genügend über optische Sachen geredet,
wie viele Leute dieses Podcasts total unansprechend sind.
Kommen wir mal zu einer unserer beliebtesten Sektionen.
Den GitHub-Star der Woche.
Hast du dir ein gutes ausgesucht?
Also ich habe mitgebracht RapidCheck.
RapidCheck ist eine Implementierung von QuickCheck in C++.
Und wenn ihr QuickCheck nicht kennt,
dann solltet ihr euch das auf jeden Fall mal angucken.
Das ist ursprünglich eine hessige Implementierung
für Property-Based Testing.
Und Property-Based Testing heißt,
du beschreibst irgendwelche Daten
und irgendwelche Eigenschaften,
die deine Funktion erfüllen muss,
wenn auf diese Daten angewendet wird.
Zum Beispiel sowas wie,
du hast einen Serialisierer
und eine Serialisierungsfunktion
und eine Deserialisierungsfunktion.
Und wenn die beide miteinander verkettet werden,
dann muss das Ergebnis wieder das gleiche sein.
Also ich serialisiere
ein paar Daten
und ich deserialisiere die wieder
und das Ergebnis muss dann wieder das
unserialisierte sein.
Genau, das kann man,
gibt es in ganz vielen Sprachen.
Also ich kenne das in Java.
Hast du das sogar schon für Rust gesehen?
Genau, in Rust gibt es das.
Ich habe das auch schon für JavaScript benutzt
und gibt es halt auch
eine sehr, sehr gute C++-Implementierung davon.
Und das Schöne,
daran ist, in so starker Typensprachen
kann man das anhand des
Typsystems relativ gut
beschreiben, wie die Daten aussehen sollen.
Das führt dann
zu sowas wie, du hast
eine Liste
von Integern und
das RapidCheck weiß, wie es
Listen von Dingen generiert und es weiß,
wie es Integer generiert, also kann man
ganz auch automatisch Listen von Integern
generieren und da ja eigentlich
im Grunde genommen ganz viele von deinen Daten
irgendwie aufgebaut sind aus so einem Grund
Grundelementen
kannst du das dann eigentlich
auf alles recht gut rekursiv anwenden.
Und wenn es mal nicht auf irgendwas Kleines passt,
dann kannst du dir auch so eine Generatoren selber schreiben.
Wenn ich jetzt so einen Serialisierer habe,
so ein YAML-Parser oder sowas,
muss ich ja trotzdem mein Input erstmal valides YAML erzeugen.
Wie würde es passieren?
Oder erzeugst mir
zufällige Datenstrukturen,
serialisiert die dann und deserialisiert die dann wieder?
Genau, also du musst
halt auch immer aufpassen, dass du auch wirklich,
Also es ist nicht die einzige Art und Weise, wie du sowas testen solltest,
weil wenn du halt irgendwie zu Schrott serialisierst
und aus Schrott wieder anderen Schrott rausziehst,
dann kann es auch sein, dass es dann grün ist,
obwohl du eigentlich nichts Sinnvolles tust.
Aber ich sage es ja eher so, um so eine Unit-Test-Suite zu ergänzen
und um diese ganzen Edge-Cases, für die du eigentlich normalerweise,
weil du zu voll bist, keine Tests schreibst, um die dann rauszufinden.
Wie unterscheidet sich das von Fuzzing?
Genau, das ist ein relativ ähnlicher Ansatz.
Also Fuzzing ist ja vor allen Dingen so aus der Security-Ecke kommt das.
Bei Fuzzing benutzt man halt für unstrukturierte Daten.
Also meistens ist das so eine Funktion,
wo du einen Speicherbereich mit einfach irgendwie
einem random Speicherbereich mit einer Adresse und einer Länge
dir von dem Fuzzer geben lässt
und die dann in deinen
Parser schmeißt.
Und das Einzige, was der dann
probiert, ist, ob das
Ganze noch crasht.
Ob das crasht oder nicht.
Bei RapidCheck...
Ich kenne so lange vorne rauschen rein, bis es umfällt.
Genau.
Also moderne Fasser,
die sind halt noch ein bisschen schlauer.
Die gucken dann in deinem
Binärcode, der wird dann noch
instrumentiert, wenn der kompiliert wird, gucken die dann,
welche Codephade betreten werden und welche nicht betreten werden
und verändern dann den Input so,
dass sie dann möglichst viele Codephade betreten.
Das können wir vielleicht in der Shownote verlinken.
Es gab jetzt neulich auf Hacker News so einen Artikel,
wo jemand PNG-Bilder erstellt hat, einfach durch den Fasser.
Also die Bedingung war, es ist ein valides PNG rausgefallen
und das ist dann quasi zufällig erzeugt aus nichts PNG-Bilder.
Das ist aber was anderes, weil es halt nicht unbedingt Eigenschaften überprüft,
die du selber definieren musst.
Also das heißt, er hat zufällige Daten erzeugt und immer dann,
wenn der Pauser nicht umgefallen ist, war es ein gültiges PNG-Bild oder wie?
Ja.
War das hier dieses American Fuzzy Lob?
Genau, also bei den Fassern gibt es eigentlich zwei populäre.
das ist einmal AFL,
American Fuzzing Lob
und den LVM
Fuzzer.
Aber wir haben ja gerade mit RapidCheck
angefangen. Genau, mit RapidCheck.
RapidCheck ist eine echt schöne Implementierung
davon in C++. Ich glaube von
jemanden von
Spotify.
Schmeiß mal in die Shownotes mal rein.
Ja.
Aber egal welche Programmiersprache
ihr programmiert, wenn ihr noch
nicht QuickCheck benutzt oder kennt,
dann probiert das mal aus. Das ist ganz toll und lohnt
sich für spezielle Anwendungsfälle,
aber dann kann es einem
wirklich einen Haufen Arbeit abnehmen und ganz viele Bugs.
Besonders dann, wenn man halt Anwendungen schreibt,
die User-Input entgegennehmen.
Das machen ja nicht
so viele, aber
ein paar machen das schon.
Deswegen sollte man
reinlassen.
Von User-Input kommt nie was
Sinnvolles. Was das RapidCheck
ist so ein State-Based Testing.
Das ist nochmal ein bisschen was anderes.
Da beschreibst du in dem RapidCheck
so eine Struktur, die den State deiner Anwendung darstellt
und beschreibst Operationen darauf,
die den State verändern
und beschreibst dann auch Expectations,
wie der aussehen soll.
Also zum Beispiel könntest du da mit GUI-Testing machen.
Du könntest quasi sagen, egal welche Buttons der User klickt,
Es sollte nie
ein negativer
Bankkonto,
Betrag auf dem Bankkonto auskommen oder sowas.
Also so eine Sachen kann man damit auch
beschreiben, komplizierter.
Das hätten die Leute von Numbers 26 mal machen sollen, oder?
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
ob die sowas da
das Ding geholfen hätte.
Die hatten ja wirklich grundlegendere Probleme.
Aber die scheinen irgendwie Probleme mit ihrem
Softwareentwicklungsablauf zu haben.
Die scheinen Probleme damit zu haben, Prioritäten richtig zu setzen.
Wenn du eine Bank sein willst und wirklich eine eigene Bank
oder generell mit Nutzerdaten umgehst und in dem Fall mit Geld von Nutzern umgehst,
dann solltest du bitte auch jemandem im Team sagen,
der ein bisschen darauf achtet, dass du Dinge absicherst.
Wenn du eine Schnittstelle nach außen gibst und du entwickelst einen Endpoint,
von dem ein Nutzer sagen kann, er möchte von A nach B Geld schicken
und das wird nirgendwo verifiziert, ob er das überhaupt darf.
Warum gibt es sowas?
Könnt ihr nochmal kurz beschreiben, was da passiert ist?
Sorry, das baut auf einem Talk auf vom Kongress, der heißt Shut Up and Take My Money, ein wunderbar toller Talk, der ein bisschen die Number26-App auseinander nimmt.
Ein bisschen sehr und unglaublich unterhaltsam und die haben halt wirklich so viel Mist gemacht, nicht nur meiner Meinung nach, sondern generell.
Die witzigsten Dinge wie, sozusagen hat es Passwort vergessen, möchte es zurücksetzen, sagt letztendlich in der App, ich habe mein Passwort vergessen, kriegt eine E-Mail.
ein Passwort-Reset-Link drin ist, kennt man ja das Prinzip.
Bloß der Request,
den ich von der App aus absetze an den Server,
um das Passwort zurückzusetzen,
wenn ich den manuell absetze, sehe ich das in der
Response, die in der App natürlich nicht angezeigt wird,
sehe ich, dass in der Response von dem
Get-Request direkt mit drinsteckt,
was auch immer ein Request war,
der Link, der in der Mail drinsteht,
den ich nutze, um das Passwort zurückzusetzen, das heißt,
ein Angreifer muss den Request absetzen, hat den Link
zum Resetten selbst schon in der Hand und kann
einfach weitermachen. Das muss man doch manuell
implementieren, so ein Scheiß, das passiert doch nicht einfach
aus Versehen. Das sieht aus, als ob da ganz viele
T-Bug-Laden sind.
Ja, vielleicht.
Oder dann haben sie halt, damit sie die Siri-Integration
hinbekommen und ich
Siri sagen kann, hey Siri, schick mal bitte
Geld an Person, so viel Geld an Person,
so und so, haben sie quasi
wirklich einen Endpoint gehabt, der hielt
sogar Slash Unverified oder so,
wo ich sage, so viel Geld von Person A
zu Person B und das wird dann einfach gemacht
und sie nutzen natürlich schlaue
Algorithmen in Airquotes,
die Abuse verhindern.
Und dann haben sie einfach mal spaßenshalber
ein paar hundert oder tausend Request
mit jeweils einem Cent abgesetzt
innerhalb von 20 Minuten.
Und das hat halt einfach alles problemlos funktioniert.
Das ist doch einfach nur.
Sehr schön. Kann man das auch in Podcasts benutzen,
um automatische Donations von den Leuten?
Hallo Siri.
Bitte überweise 400 Euro
auf das Konto von Hendrik.
Okay, Google,
die gibt auch mal Kontext.
Bestellen wir bitte hinterher
noch ein Puppenhaus.
Wie war das mit
diesem Tweet gelesen,
wenn Jeff Bezos mit seinem
Amazon Echo spricht? Hey Alexa,
buy something from Whole Foods.
Okay, buy in Whole Foods.
Ich höre einen Podcast.
Du hast den Request, den ich
von der App aus absetze an den Server,
um das Passwort zurückzusetzen.
Wenn ich den manuell absetze, sehe ich das
in der Response, die in der App natürlich nicht angezeigt wird,
sehe ich das in der Response
von dem Get-Request direkt mit drinsteckt,
was auch immer der Request war,
der Link, der in der Mail drinsteht,
den ich nutze und das Wasser zurückgesetzt habe.
Das heißt, ein Angreifer muss den Request absetzen,
hat den Link zum Resetten selbst schon in der Hand
und kann dann einfach weitermachen.
Das muss man doch manuell implementieren,
so ein Scheiß, das passiert doch nicht einfach aus Versehen.
Das sah mir so aus, als ob da ganz viele Debug-
Ja, vielleicht.
Oder dann haben sie halt, damit sie die Siri-Integration
hinbekommen und ich Siri sagen kann,
hey Siri, schick mal bitte Geld an Person,
so viel Geld an Person, so und so.
haben sie quasi wirklich einen Endpoint gehabt,
der hielt sogar Slash Unverified oder so,
wo ich sage, so viel Geld von Person A zu Person B
und das wird dann einfach gemacht.
Und sie nutzen natürlich schlaue Algorithmen in Air Quotes,
die Abuse verhindern.
Und dann haben sie einfach mal spaßenshalber,
ich glaube, ein paar hundert oder tausend Request
mit jeweils einem Cent abgesetzt innerhalb von 20 Minuten.
Und das hat halt einfach alles problemlos funktioniert.
Sehr schön.
Kann man das auch in Podcasts benutzen,
automatische Donations von Ihnen.
Hallo Siri,
bitte überweise 400 Euro
auf das Konto von Hendrik.
Okay Google, delete all my contacts.
Bestell mir bitte
hinterher noch ein Puppenhaus.
Wie war das mit
diesem Tweet gelesen,
wenn Jeff Bezos mit seinem
Amazon Echo spricht, hey Alexa,
buy something from Whole Foods,
okay, buy in Whole Foods.
Wir haben
Whole Foods gekauft.
Ich höre einen Podcast,
der Hoax Söder,
das heißt einer von den Moderatoren,
das ist so ein Ehepaar aus Hamburg,
die heißen Alex und Alexa.
Ich sehe mir jedes Mal,
wenn irgendjemand diesen Podcast hört
und das Laut in seiner Wohnung hat,
dann macht es irgendwo im Raum bling.
Ich wollte aber eigentlich gerade
auf ein anderes Thema eingehen.
Meine Überleitung, die ich machen wollte,
war zum Thema Bike-Shedding.
Wenn man über Softwareentwicklungsprozesse redet,
kann man sich ja herrlich über Sachen streiten.
Und da ist mir nämlich etwas Lustiges passiert.
Neulich wurde ich zu einem Bikeshitting-Meeting eingeladen.
Das hieß auch direkt so?
Ich habe ein Meeting gehabt, remote, mit einem Kollegen.
Und der hatte gemeint, ja, über solche Themen,
da unterhalten wir uns meistens gar nicht mehr,
weil es nimmt so viel Zeit ein.
Aber weil es dann doch irgendwie mal interessant wurde,
haben wir da einen extra Termin irgendwie in der Woche gemacht,
wo wir dann nur noch über sowas reden.
Da ist das aus dem Weg.
Wenn jemand so ein Thema anbringt,
dann sagen wir, gut, okay,
da sprechen wir bei dem Bikeshitting-Meeting drüber.
und ich habe gesagt, das ist ja total witzig,
daraufhin wurde ich auch in dieses Meeting eingeladen,
die sitzen an einem anderen Ort und da habe ich dann
Remote teilgenommen und
da stand dann in dem Invite
Back by Popular Demand, Bike Shading
Weekly. Wirst du den Begriff
Bike Shading oder Yak Shaving generell mal
kurz erklären?
Also, dass Yak Shaving das gleiche ist,
möchte ich... Ach nee, das waren unterschiedliche
Dinge, oder? Also, Bike Shading,
es gab wohl mal,
zum einen gibt es einen wunderschönen Podcast, der
in Anlehnung daran The Bike Shit heißt.
Aber tatsächlich gab es wohl mal
irgendeine Vorstandssitzung von irgendeiner Firma,
die sich eine Stunde lang oder mehrere Stunden lang
darüber geschritten haben, in welche Farbe
sie den Fahrradstander streichen sollen,
den Bike Shit.
Und weil das so sinnlos und
zu nichts führend war, man sich aber herrlich
darüber streiten konnte, wie man da vorgehen soll,
wurde diese Art
des Diskutierens um Kleinigkeiten,
wo aber jeder eine Meinung hat,
die aber alle unterschiedlich sind,
hinterher als Bike Shit bezeichnet.
Okay, ich habe gerade mal nachgeschlagen,
Yakshaving geht aber in eine ähnliche Richtung.
A less useful activity
done consciously or subconsciously
to procrastinate about a larger but more
useful task. Also du musst irgendwas
machen, um dir eigentliche Sachen so ein bisschen aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Ja, das
mache ich auch sehr gerne.
Heißt das nicht, prokrastinieren?
Aber Yakshaving ist quasi, wenn du
was Kompliziertes machst, um zu
prokrastinieren, was aber vielleicht
Aber less useful
ist zumindest
in der Definitions-Betition. Zum Beispiel,
du hast dieses Code-Generation-Tool,
was ich neulich mal angefasst habe, um damit
noch andere Definitionsdateien
auszuspucken. Und das hat
dummerweise unnötige
Leerzeilen zwischen
Klassendefinitionen ausgespuckt.
Da habe ich heute
zehn Minuten meiner Arbeitszeit drauf verwendet,
das wegzumachen, dass das diese
Leerzeilen ausspuckt. Das ist aber wichtig, so was.
Das ist total wichtig. Der autogenerierte
C++-Code wesentlich anschaulicher.
Ich habe übrigens jetzt zum ersten Mal Go gemacht.
Oh Gott.
Das war dieses Tool.
Ah, das ist in Go geschrieben.
Hast du mal gesagt, du hast irgendwie ein Go-Tool,
das die Windows generiert und jetzt auch
TypeScript oder so?
Genau, genau.
Es gibt einen Standard, der heißt
JSON-Schema.
Der definiert einfach
so eine Art DTD für JSON.
Das ist einfach
die Struktur von einem JSON-Dokument.
Und das kann man nur herrlich verwenden,
um damit Code zu generieren,
der entweder dieses JSON validiert
oder dieses JSON erzeugt.
Und das gab es bereits
für C++.
Hat der Jupp gebaut irgendwann mal.
Und ich habe es noch gebraucht,
um mir eine Type-Definition
für TypeScript auszuspucken.
Und dementsprechend waren es irgendwie
fünf Zeilen, die ich hinzugefügt habe
bei den richtigen Stellen.
Kompiliert schön schnell.
Ist doch eine ganz nette Sprache.
Das sind die Vorteile von Go.
Kompiliert schnell.
Was mich total gewundert hat, ist, dass es
absolut nichts ausspuckt, wenn es kompiliert.
Also du sagst,
dementsprechend schreibst du dann irgendwann
nur noch Go, Build,
mein Zeug und und, dann führst du direkt aus.
Du kannst es auch als Interpreter quasi
fast nehmen.
Ja, und führst du das aus, Emilia.
Genau.
Ja, Go hat echt schönes Tooling.
Geht so, das würde ich
jetzt ungern direkt so unterstreichen
wollen. Also gerade Dependency
Management ist immer selten kaputt wie in Go.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die Penalty Management ist ein
großer Schmerzpunkt, aber
so der Compiler und
so statische
Analyse-Tools
wie Race Condition
Sucher für deine Integration-Tests,
da gibt es schon ganz
tolle Sachen.
Visualisierung von deiner Parallelität
als WebGL-Webseite.
Aha.
Ja, da gibt es
ganz tolle Sachen. Und was auch richtig, richtig
cool ist, ist Go-Format.
Weil in der
Go-Community ist es so, dass
es gibt eigentlich nur eine Art und Weise
Code zu formatieren.
Und das ist die Art und Weise, wie
das Go-Format-Tool das ausspuckt,
wenn du deinen Code dadurch pipest.
Und
es gibt eigentlich da keine, also
in der Go-Community gibt es keine Bike-Shedding
Meetings über
Spaces, Tabs, Einrückungen,
solche Sachen. Lustiger
Weitereweise formatiert das sogar das in Tabs,
was eigentlich ja heutzutage
nicht mehr so der State of the Art ist, aber
prinzipiell ist das total toll, weil da gibt es einfach keinen Streit mehr
um sowas. Großer Freund von Autofomatierern
bin ich ja nicht wirklich. Ich mag das.
Du bist auch so jemand, der besonders viel Wert drauf
legt, bestimmte Parameter zu alignen und
das halt genauso. Ja, aber die können alignen, das hast du kaum
einen. Ich würde gerne das haben, dass ein
Formatter genau das eben mitmacht.
Und dann wäre das, das macht ein guter
Formatter in meinen Augen, das machen sehr wenige.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was überhaupt einer macht.
Das ist aber auch eine Kunst, das zu machen. Also ich mache
Solche Sachen mache ich dann halt in Vim.
Da gibt es so ein Plugin, das heißt Tabularize.
Das erkennt entweder den Block, in dem du gerade bist,
oder du kannst den Block auswählen
und dann kannst du ein Zeichen angeben,
nachdem du es tabularisieren möchtest.
Das ist dann meistens das Ist-Gleich oder ein Colon oder ein Pfeil.
Und dann werden einfach dieses Zeichen überall,
wo es vorkommt, vertikal ausgerichtet.
Und dann hast du eine Tabelle draus gemacht.
Ja, es gibt für Emacs auch MetaX-Line-X.
Also wenn das in sowas wie Clang-Format oder Rust-Format
format eingebaut wäre. Ja, also Goformat
macht das standardmäßig ziemlich stark.
Das ist nämlich auch einer der...
Es gibt ein bisschen
man kann auch Optionen, aber
es ist eigentlich nicht üblich, dass man das macht.
Ich habe einmal in die Issues geschaut von Goformat,
weil ich da eine Option gesucht habe
für etwas, ich weiß leider nicht mehr, was es war,
was mich genervt hatte und die
Issues, ich fand das großartig, also großartig
in ganz großen Anführungsstrichen, die Issues
sind voll von Leuten, die die Optionen vorschlagen
und sich winzige Dinge wünschen und die Maintainer
einfach so, nein, sowas gibt es hier nicht,
Es gibt nur diese eine normale Art und weiter.
Okay, ich werde ganz bestimmt nichts vorschlagen.
Das ist so, was mich an Go stört.
Die Community ist so unfreundlich gefühlt.
Wenn einer gefragt, warum sind die ganzen Beispiele
alle nicht in Syntax-Highlighting?
Das kann man ja ganz schlecht lesen.
Und dann der eine Hauptentwickler sagt,
mir wurde als Kind mit Farben Sachen erklärt,
aber jetzt sind wir erwachsen, wir machen sowas nicht mehr.
Es gibt immer unfreundliche Leute irgendwo.
Ja, ich glaube, die hast du eigentlich überall.
Sorry, ich hatte dich gerade unterbrochen gehabt.
beim Formatter Optionen.
Genau, ich wollte nur sagen,
ein wirklicher guter Vorteil davon,
dass man so eine Tools nutzt, um den Code zu formatieren,
ist, man kann dann auch obskur komplizierte
Formatting Rules auch nehmen,
weil wenn das alle benutzen,
das mechanisch zu formatieren,
dann kann man auch sowas sagen,
wie allein das alles
an einer Stelle immer die ganze Zeit,
was ja manuell
im Editor, wenn du keinen Editor-Support
dafür hast, eine totale
Arbeit wäre, aber wenn alles
so ein Tuning ist es nicht mehr kompliziert.
Das Problem ist, wenn du es irgendwo einführst,
musst du die Konfiguration von deinem Formatter
immer mitschleppen als Teil des Repos,
damit alle das immer gleich machen und sich nicht mal
gegenseitig wieder zurückformatieren.
Und wenn du es einmal eingestellt hast,
dann gibt es Leute,
die sagen,
wir formatieren das bitte nicht nochmal,
weil das zerstört ja die Git-History von den Dateien.
Da kann man nicht mehr mit Blame sehen,
wer diese Zeile geschrieben hat.
Ja, aber das ist Bullshit.
Dafür gibt es ja Git-Blame
no white space oder so.
Also man kann auch die Historie
mit ohne white space
schaust da einfach noch ein bisschen
weiter in der History zurück, bis du tatsächlich
die Erinnerung siehst.
Also ja, das ist auch
irgendwie, das ist auch so eine Religionsfrage
glaube ich so ein bisschen. Da kann man
sich auch vortrefflich drüber streiten, aber
das ist schon mal eine Meta-Ebene höher, als sich
dann über die Tabs und Spaces an sich zu streiten.
Und das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool, weil
gerade bei Pull-Requests finde ich
ist es total schädlich, wenn die Leute sich
über so eine ganz, ganz
Low-Level-Sachen unterhalten.
Wenn sie sich eigentlich ihre wertvolle Zeit
damit verbringen könnten, über
Design-Fragen oder
über irgendwie
sinnvolle Namen für Dinge, was ja auch ein
ziemlich kompliziertes Thema ist, wo man
hoffentlich Zeit reinversenken könnte und zu verbringen.
Oder Fehler am Code des anderen finden.
Oder logische Fehler finden oder
Fragen, warum man kein Unit-Test geschrieben hat
für diese Funktion.
Ich schreibe Pull-Requests an einen Repo
wo die Leute dann schreiben, schmeiß dir mal
Klankformat drauf und
füge mal eine Leerzeile ein und sortiere mal
bitte diese
Zuweisung um und
schreib mal diese Funktion nach unten.
Damit vergraulst du dir
gerade in der Open-Source-Welt so viele
Leute, die mithelfen würden und
Pull-Requests mit zu deinem Kram absetzen.
Helf bei den offensichtlichen Dingen, finde Fehler,
merge das und dann fixe es selber, wenn es dich
das Ding stört. Ja, genau, das kannst du dann annehmen
und wenn es dich stört, dann machst du es selber hinterher nochmal anders.
Aber da fiel mir ein, es gibt schon sowas wie Merchbots,
die schauen vorher, wenn du einen Pull-Request machst,
dass das baut und dass du damit nichts anderes kaputt machst
und dass es merchbar ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe da schon irgendwo mal von gehört,
es gibt auch so Linterbots.
Du machst einfach deinen Pull-Request, du machst einfach deinen Commit,
du musst es nicht bei dir formatieren.
Das nächste Mal, wenn du es pullst, ist es formatiert worden.
Ich habe sowas schon gehört für Leute, die in ihrer Firma
dann modernere C++-Regeln einführen wollten.
die haben dann die Leute einfach ihren alten Scheiß schreiben lassen
und die haben dann hinterher
einfach ein Bot einmal nachts,
also alle Commits,
die die Leute gemacht haben, dann nochmal alles hinterher
umgestrickt und dann am nächsten Tag
sah es dann halt anders aus.
Das ist deine Kid-History, war dann auch immer.
Da läuft dann halt einmal, hast du einmal
am Tag so einen Commit von irgendeinem Bot.
Hoffentlich, die es kaputt macht.
Den könnte man dann bei Blame eventuell einfach
ausfiltern. Also was halt richtig schön wäre,
vielleicht hört das ja jetzt jemand von den
Hörern und baut, das wäre, wenn
du an dem Pull Request dann für so ein Bot
einen Kommentar reinschreiben soll,
würde, übrigens, deine Formatierung ist nicht ganz okay,
klick mal hier, um das zu fixen
und dann klickst du rauf und dann
committet der unter deinem Namen dann
noch ein
Commit auf den Branch mit fix
Formatting und
dann ist das okay.
Wenn der das einfach für dich machen würde.
Es gibt ja viele
Merch-Bots, die einfach schon
die Kommentare in den
Reviews mitlesen.
Also du kannst, wenn du einen Pull-Request zum Beispiel an Rust machst,
dann kriegst du als erstes eine Antwort von einem Bot, High Five.
Das ist dann so ein Bild von einer, die Hand hebt, High Five.
Der weist dir dann zufällig einen Reviewer zu.
Der Reviewer sagt dann irgendwann, okay, check.
Und dann sagt er einem anderen Bot,
okay, jetzt kannst du das mal zu einer Liste von Sachen hinzufügen.
Und dann werden die ganzen Pull-Requests,
die an dem Tag oder in dem Zeitraum approved wurden,
werden dann so batchweise
auf einmal gemerged von MerchBot.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, gerade bei größeren Sachen.
Das ist dann Boss.
Das ist Boss, genau. Oder Homo, je nachdem, wo man gerade ist.
Beides der gleiche Code.
Was ich auch noch finde, wenn man so eine Argumente hat,
also wenn man sich dann mit den Argumenten darüber streitet,
habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht.
Was du halt sagen kannst ist,
wenn du so drauf bist, kannst du sagen,
sagt jemand, die Formatierung gefällt mir aber nicht,
dann sage ich, okay, okay, erinnern wir.
Kein Problem, mir ist es eigentlich egal,
wie das am Ende aussieht. Mir ist es einfach wichtiger,
dass es automatisch passiert.
Weil so kannst du dann zumindest,
bist du halt raus aus der Nummer,
dann gibt es keinen Streit mehr drum.
Und wenn da irgendwie zwei Leute dann was
unterschiedliches wollen, dann kannst du die dann aufeinander verweisen,
dass die sich gegenseitig streiten.
GitHub hat ja vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
auch ein recht nettes Feature eingebaut,
dass du bei PRs standardmäßig aktiv,
kannst aber auch ausschalten, wenn du möchtest,
dem Maintainer des Repos
Rechte gibst, auf deinem PR-Branch
drauf zu committen. Und so kann der Dinge,
Kleinigkeiten, die nerven, wie Format und Gras,
auch selber fixen einfach.
Und da direkt mit draufschmeißen, weil ich ja normalerweise unter deinem Namen
dann der Fork, auf den du den PR
geschrieben hast. Das ging früher nicht.
Das finde ich eine nette Edition.
Es war manchmal ein bisschen weird, wenn jemand einen PR stellt
und dann einfach man selber auf den PR
dazwischen committet und der sich dann wundert, warum er jetzt
auf seinem PR irgendwelche Chances
hat, die er lokal nicht hat, da ich mal was
mergen muss. Aber das ist ja
okay. Die Alternative ist ja,
dass da jemand dann,
dass du irgendwie drei Mini-Sachen
anmeckerst, der PA-Steller
dann keine Lust mehr drauf hat, die noch zu fixen
und das Ding dann liegen bleibt und am Ende kopierst
du das dann seinen Branche
zu dir lokal und kommitest das selber und der hat halt
nicht mal die Attribution zu den Sachen, die er dann gemacht hat.
Das finde ich dann schon eine echt sinnvolle
Alternative dazu.
Das ist besser, als wenn es dann einfach liegen bleibt.
Die Leute haben auch, wenn sie dir
Proorquest schicken, haben sie auch bessere Sachen zu tun
als die Afformittierung oder deinem
dem Style hinterher zu rennen.
Gerade wenn es halt Contributions
sind von Dritten, die halt generell
nirgendwo dafür bezahlt werden, sondern einfach mal
ihre Freizeit opfern, um bei irgendeinem
Projekt von dir oder was du halt mit maintainst,
was zu fixen, was zu lernen.
Sowas ist mir ja noch nicht passiert. Ich hatte ja bei, das hatte ich glaube ich
in der letzten Folge schon erzählt, bei
This Week in Rust, bei
Call for Contributions,
mal um Feature gebeten für eine von
Main Libraries, wo ich keine Zeit hatte, das umzusetzen.
So ein, zwei Wochen später kam uns tatsächlich
einer, hier, guck mal, habe ich gemacht, kannst du dir mal angucken,
was hältst du davon? Ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig,
das könnte man immer noch machen, aber so und so.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, super geil, cool, danke,
das können wir gerne so machen.
Dann kam von ihm erstmal nichts mehr.
Dann irgendwann habe ich halt gesagt,
du, ich würde das gerne übernehmen,
magst du mal einen Pull-Request machen?
Dann kam wieder nichts.
Da habe ich dir jetzt irgendwie verkrault, habe ich auch was falsch gesagt oder sowas.
Vielleicht ist er auch im Urlaub, keine Ahnung, wer weiß.
Und nochmal eine Woche später habe ich dann gesagt,
du, ich würde jetzt einfach mal von dir pullen,
da kommt ja der ursprüngliche Name Pull-Request her,
und das einfach was übernehmen musst oder gemacht hast.
Bist du damit verstanden?
Hallo?
Dann habe ich es halt irgendwann einfach gemacht.
Ja, klar.
Irgendwie hatte man mein Meepo gefurkt und
einfach was committed, anscheinend um lokal
damit Spaß zu haben und dann habe ich einfach seine
Changes zu einem PR gemacht auf dem
Original bei mir und dann einfach
als PR mit seinem Commit gemerged,
ohne dass er überhaupt was damit zu tun hatte.
Kann man auch das machen? Aber ich hatte
mal bei einem Projekt, das war einfach
so eine witzige kleine Sammlung an ein paar
Server-Frameworks, das heißt einfach,
which is the fastest, ein sehr
unscientific Benchmark von ein paar
kleinen Server-Frameworks und ich fand es einfach
witzig und nett und habe dann mal
Rocket RS dazwischen geworfen
und kurze Zeit später,
ein paar Tage später, kam dann der
Rocket-Maintainer, Sergio Benitez
und hat halt in dem PR einfach mal noch ein bisschen
was gefixt, was er
als sinnvoll ansah, hat den PR aber
direkt wieder geclosed und gesagt, das ist bloß eine
Anmerkung, wie es vielleicht besser läuft.
wenn sie keiner fix, war auch sinnvoll,
einfach eine Allocation, den unnötig haben,
rausgenommen, hat den PR direkt geclosed,
weil es bloß anmerken wollte.
Und dann hat er nochmal einen neuen PR aufgemacht,
mit seinen Änderungen, seinem Commit,
und dann, okay, wäre es doch das einfach
rein mir komisch.
Das ist ja auch so ein Typ mit einer
krassen History
an Jobs.
Echt?
Der ist,
da meine ich den Raussuche, also der
Entwickler und Maintainer von
Rocket RS, ein kleines,
aber beliebtes
Web-Framework. Places I've worked
at. At SpaceX. Apple.
Google. Okay.
Krass. I founded and developed
so und so a couple of
technology-oriented companies.
Und der Typ sieht
nicht aus, als wäre er über 40.
Der sieht sogar noch aus, als hätte er Zeit, Sport zu machen.
So ist er auf Rocket gekommen wahrscheinlich.
Über SpaceX.
Deswegen heißt es jetzt Rocket.
Aber der hat einen PhD at Stanford
und bei MIT noch studiert.
Das hat er gemacht bisher.
Vielleicht ist das ein Jugendfoto.
Kannst du gerade sagen.
Nee, der hat bei dem
Rust Meetup in
San Francisco bei dem offiziellen,
was auf air.mozilla.org
immer als Video anguckbar ist.
Sehr empfehlenswert übrigens.
Hat er irgendwann mal einen Vortrag über Rocket gehalten.
Der sieht wirklich nicht aus,
als wäre das ein altes Foto von ihm.
Aber er hat bei Apple auch jeweils nur drei Monate
gearbeitet.
Ach so.
Da können wir es heute nur mittlerweile alles aufzählen.
Bei Gmail und bei Apple war ja auch ein Intern
bei irgendwas
Mac-O-Weiß-Counts.
Aber trotzdem, ich meine,
es ist auf jeden Fall auf dem Leben.
Wenn du einmal bei einer von diesen Firmen gearbeitet hast,
dann bist du, glaube ich,
nur noch in der Ecke unterwegs
und dann arbeitest du halt, nachdem du bei Google warst,
bei Apple oder bei SpaceX
oder bei Hoolies, keine Ahnung.
Bei Hoolie?
Bei Pipe Piper.
zum Anfang.
Mittlerweile sind da genug Folgen von raus, dass ich das
letztendlich mal gucken kann. Hast du das nicht gemacht?
Boah, schaust du dir an, die neue Staffel ist so gut.
Ja, ja.
Also es gibt mittlerweile vier oder fünf Folgen, sechs
vielleicht sogar schon.
Dadurch, dass sie 20 Minuten lang sind,
möchte ich nicht irgendwie 20 Minuten so eine Folge gucken
und dann eine Woche drauf warten.
Die sind so unterhaltsam.
Okay, für die Uninitiierten.
Was ist Piper?
Es gibt eine
Serie, das ist so eine Art
Sitcom mit 20 Minuten Folgen.
Das ist keine Sitcom.
Das ist eine Community-Serie.
Silicon Valley,
den Arbeitsalltag von Softwareentwicklern
im Silicon Valley.
Darüber spitzt aber unglaublich.
Also Softwareentwickler, Entrepreneurs,
Startup-Gründer,
Leute, die in solchen
Incubatoren leben und hausen
und Leute, die bei so großen Softwarefirmen
wie Google arbeiten. Google gibt es da nicht,
aber Hoolies.
Und Startup,
um das sich die Serie dreht, heißt Pipe Piper.
und die machen
Compression in erster Linie.
Es macht einfach nur Spaß,
ich möchte nicht spoilern.
Ich würde es wärmstens empfehlen.
Ich habe heute in einem Stand-Up
eine Silicon Valley-Referenz gebracht
und ich war fast ein bisschen traurig,
dass keiner es gemacht hat.
Ich habe ein bisschen rumexperimentiert,
wir wollen ja irgendwie hier zwischen
JavaScript und C++,
wo wir ja Daten hin und her schicken als JSON
und wir wollen ja aufpassen, dass das Datenformat
weil Nenntem das gleiche ist, also müssen wir
das irgendwo validieren.
Jetzt generiere ich also, ich habe mir also diese Typen
da in TypeScript hingeschrieben,
daraus konnte ich mit einem von zwei Tools
JSON-Schema generieren
und damit konnte ich mit einem Tool
C++ generieren.
Jetzt brauche ich es aber eigentlich
in die andere Richtung, ich will aber nicht
C++-Typen hinschreiben müssen, also dann schreibe ich
lieber JSON-Schema, das heißt, ich mache das so
inside out,
dass ich halt dieses JSON-Schema habe, mit dem ich
sowohl Typen für TypeScript
als auch den C++-Code generieren kann.
Das ist eine Referenz aus...
Du musst die Serie anschauen.
Aus Silicon Valley.
Das lohnt sich so sehr.
Ich habe Leute gehört,
die finden die Serie sehr traurig,
oder zumindest
Silicon Valley an sich immer abschreckender
aufgrund dieser Serie.
Ich muss sagen,
gerade aufgrund dieser Serie hätte ich noch mehr Lust dazu.
Also ich muss sagen, durch die erste Folge
habe ich mich ein bisschen durchgequält.
Danach wird es wesentlich weniger besser.
aber muss sich mit den Charakteren erst mal anfreunden.
Aber was ich zum Beispiel auch ziemlich geil finde,
ist, dass die eigentlich fast alle Firmen,
die nicht direkt Leute aus diesen Firmen zeigen,
gibt es wirklich.
Also die sprechen wirklich über Uber, über Slack,
über Twitter, über andere Firmen.
Das Intro alleine ist immer auch schon so.
In den Intro kommen ganz viele Logos von diesen 12 Firmen vor.
Und für die eine Charakterin, die sie da vorgestellt haben,
die irgendwie davon erzählt hat,
dass sie jetzt die ganze Zeit mit KI arbeitet,
bei Facebook,
dass sie das und das gemacht hat.
Die hat nur so beiläufig in einem Satz mal erzählt,
dass sie Neural Networks
verwendet hat, um Atari-Spiele damit
spielen zu lassen. Dann hast du halt
irgendwann gesehen, dass die wirklich da für
eine Szene, wo sie mal kurz einen Bildschirm gezeigt haben,
einen GitHub-Account von ihr angelegt haben
und da irgendwie die letzten halben
Jahre mit History gefüllt haben, einfach
wo dann irgendwelche Atari-Neural Networks
da drinstehen. Aber die haben auch Spaß.
Die haben ein paar coole Technical Advisor
zu der Serie, die sich echt Mühe geben.
Und ich möchte es nicht allzu großes Spoilern von der aktuellen Staffel.
Aber da gibt es eine Szene, wo es eine App gibt, die kann,
ich bin mal ein bisschen zu abstrahieren, die kann Essen erkennen aufgrund von neuronalen Netzen Magic.
Und diese App haben sie tatsächlich entwickelt, die genauso funktioniert wie in der App gezeigt.
Leider gibt es sie nicht im deutschen Store aus rechtlichen Gründen für iOS,
aber zumindest im US-App Store.
Und ich finde es einfach großartig,
dass diese Apps tatsächlich genauso bekloppt,
wie sich diese Serie gezeigt wurde.
Also die ist halt sehr speziell.
Und ich möchte euch nicht vorwegnehmen,
dass die sehr witzig ist.
Also diese Serie ist wirklich an sehr vielen Stellen
wiederzufinden in Referenzen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, kennt ihr Font Awesome?
Das wollte ich gerade auch sagen.
Font Awesome ist eine Schriftart,
die man in seine Webseite einbinden kann.
Und anstatt normaler Buchstaben sind da Logos von Sachen drin.
Standard-Icons, Vorwärts, Rückwärts, Refresh, Home, Brief.
Aber auch so Twitter- und GitHub-Logos.
damit man nicht ganze Bitmaps runterladen muss.
Und in dem Set von Awesome-Zeichen
ist auch das Logo von PipePiper dabei.
Wichtige Dinge.
Die haben auch, glaube ich, tatsächlich ein Bullshit-Paper
über so manch genannte Dinge geschrieben in der Serie.
Wie das Middle-Out-Compression-Zeugs
beziehungsweise über Weisman-Scores.
Middle-Out heißt das.
Aber Inside Out gab es noch auch irgendwo.
Das war der Pixar-Film, der hieß Inside Out.
Wahrscheinlich hat deshalb keiner meine Referenz
verstanden.
Ich habe übrigens noch einen schönen GitHub-Star,
wenn wir gerade über Awesome geredet haben.
Es gibt nämlich
Awesome Terminal Fonts.
Und wenn ihr
sowas wie Wim Powerline
oder generell Powerline
kennt, dann
ist das nochmal
ein Ecke cooler, weil die haben
so von Awesome-Icons genommen, die in
Terminal-Schrift abgepackt und dann die
Prompts noch ein bisschen
gepimpt. Da gibt es auch ein Plugin für
Oh My Seashell, wenn ihr das benutzt.
Das habe ich bei dir sogar schon gesehen, stimmt.
Und da hat man dann
ganz viele Icons mehr
in seinem
Terminal. Zum Beispiel, wenn man in seinem Home-Directories
hat man so ein kleines Haus-Icon.
Wenn man im Git-Master ist, hat man
so ein M, das so in 3D
nach hinten geht.
Für
GitHub-Repos gibt es
auch ziemlich viele
Icons, die da noch mit drin sind, zum Beispiel
generell wenn du im Gid bist,
kriegst du so eine kleine Octocad.
Das ist so eine Ablage,
so ein Ablagesymbol,
das dir anzeigt, wie viele
Stashes du gerade
in dem
einzelnen Repo hast und
ein richtiges Branch-Symbol.
Die Ordner haben so einen richtigen aufgeklappten Ordner
und so. Es macht halt diese ganze
OMI-Sechelle
Powerline
Geschichte nochmal ein bisschen schicker.
Echt schicker, sehr.
Ich frage mich immer noch, warum es im Jahr
2017 immer noch nicht möglich ist,
einfach Bilder in die Kommandos-Seite
zu printen. Da müsste es auch mal
einen Standard für geben. Keinen Standard, aber
verschiedene Möglichkeiten dafür.
Mittlerweile muss es nicht mehr, weil
alle Leute Emojis irgendwie in ihre Ausgaben
mit reinprinten.
Ich habe mal zum Spaß erneut ein Bild-Skript
auf Arbeit, ein Emoji
reingepackt, einfach um so zu sehen,
an welcher Stelle das jetzt hier crasht, weil das einfach
der Lockout war irgendwie fünf Seiten lang.
Du kannst es nicht lesen.
Dann habe ich einfach was gebraucht, was da farblich rausstellt.
Was drin steht.
Und das habe ich aus Versehen mit reinkommittet.
Und dann bin ich einen Tag später
vor einem Kollegen gefragt worden.
Hast du eigentlich mal getestet, ob dann nicht hier das normale Windows-Command-Prom
crasht?
Was?
Crashed?
Nee.
Aber es ist angezeigt.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Bei Homebrew haben die ja auch irgendwann angefangen,
wenn ein Store fertig ist,
dass sie dann so ein Bier-Emoji da mit reingeworfen haben.
Das fand ich auch ziemlich lustig,
als das plötzlich nach irgendeinem Silent-Update aufgetaucht ist.
Das musste ich aber wieder rausnehmen.
Nee, das fand ich Homebrew, das war CocoPots.
CocoPots haben aber was gemacht.
Das ist die Fantasy-Manager für iOS,
somit der erste und populärste,
aber am komischsten implementierteste.
Die haben in deine Xcode-Build-Phases
und die ist mit reingeschmissen. Es hat sehr viele Leute
sehr gestört und es wohl auf sehr vielen CIs
kaputt gegangen. Da mussten sie
jetzt wieder rauspatchen, leider.
No.
Also das ist so der
Hauptvorteil, warum man
Jarn anstatt NPM nehmen möchte.
Wir haben nämlich beim Erzeugen und beim
Installieren von Sachen
auch Emojis angezeigt.
Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch.
Das hat fast alle Vorteile von Jarn auch.
Das zeigt keine Emojis auf der Seite.
Ne, unnutzbar.
ist es auch so schnell wie Jan.
Also ich benutze ja Jan größtenteils,
weil das die
ganzen Dependencies parallel ausflößt
und auch parallel downloadet.
Und da kriegt man dann
sein NPM-Inster manchmal fünfmal so schnell
fertig, wenn man viele
Dependencies hat.
Also ich schmeiße mal
einen Link in unsere Shownotes,
der heißt
Did NPM just kill Jan?
Und das heißt ja häufig so, dass du irgendwie
einen etablierten Player hast,
da kommt jemand mit einer besseren Alternative
und die ist aber nach einem halben Jahr wieder weg,
weil der etablierte Player einfach nachgezogen ist.
Und das hat halt NPM an der Stelle auch wirklich gemacht.
Also es ist nicht schneller als Jahn,
aber es ist hinreichend nah dran,
dass es mittlerweile dazu führt,
dass man nicht mehr unbedingt zu Jahn greifen muss,
aufgrund von Geschwindigkeit.
Was Jahn immer noch macht,
was NPM auch in der mittelfristigen Zukunft nicht machen wird,
ist deine
Node-Modul-Verzeichnisse
flachklopfen,
weil es da einfach zu viele
Abhängigkeiten gibt. Es gibt wohl Module,
die direkt in die Pfade rein
von ihrem Node-Modul-Verzeichnis reingreifen
und da bestimmte Sachen erwarten
und die haben sich gedacht, das ist ganz schön scheiße,
aber wir wollen jetzt eure Installation
und eure Skripte auch nicht kaputt machen,
also verändern wir das mal nicht.
Aber so allein von der Geschwindigkeit her
können sie mittlerweile ziemlich gut mitziehen.
Aber waren die Jahre auch ein gutes Stück schneller,
weil die mit Facebook-Servern gesprochen haben?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der Grund für die Geschwindigkeit ist.
Sicherlich nicht, ausschließlich.
Das wäre ein bisschen komisch, aber war das nicht eins der Dinge?
Dass sie quasi NPM gemürt haben?
Wenn das einer der Gründe ist,
dann ist NPM jetzt wirklich schneller,
weil die sind bis auf 5% an die Geschwindigkeit von Jahren angekommen.
Also ich schmeiße mir so ein Video, was ich mir da, was ich auch gefunden habe, in die Shownotes,
das NPM-Just-Kirjarn. Und das ist quasi das Faziet,
Jan hat jetzt mittlerweil nicht mehr genügend Alleinstellungsmerkmale, um NPM zu ersetzen.
Außer Emojis. Aber was passiert denn, was passiert, wenn du die Dependencies, wie du sagts, flach klopfst,
wenn die gleich
Oder liegen die auch quasi einfach nur nebenan?
In den Jahren hat er an der Stelle
Semantic Versioning
angeschmissen und hat dir die Version,
mit der du eigentlich theoretisch kompatibel sein solltest,
hingeworfen.
Und wenn es Breaking Changes gab,
also wenn du unterschiedliche Manager-Versionen hast,
dann hat er, glaube ich, einfach die Dateien
irgendwie umgemappt.
Aber ich wüsste auch nicht genau, wie das gehen soll.
Okay, so wie die anderen Dependency Manager vielleicht,
aber die verteidigt sind mit der Version
benannt und dann nebeneinander gelegt.
Das geht ja insofern eigentlich nicht, als dass der Name
Modules und die Struktur, die dauernd runterliegt,
eigentlich von Node.js vorgeschrieben ist
und nicht von deinem Paketmanager.
Das spricht ja keiner.
Wenn du dein Skript startest,
spricht das ja nicht mit NPM.
Da müsste es ja den Source auch umscheinen.
Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie das ging.
Das ist ja generell so ein interessantes Phänomen
in der Node-Welt, dass du nicht
nur irgendwie eine sinnvolle
Auflösung deiner Dependencies
und der transitiven
Dependencies von deinen Dependencies hast,
sondern dass es irgendwie möglich ist,
eine Library achtmal in unterschiedlichen Versionen drauf zu haben.
Da muss man dann auch echt drauf achten.
Sonst, also gerade bei diesen ganzen Elektronen-Apps,
ihr habt ja über Elektronen schon geredet in einer der letzten Folgen,
das ist dann manchmal so, dass du eigentlich nur fünf Dependencies hast,
aber dann irgendwie auf zwei Gigabyte und minifiziertes JavaScript kommst,
die da reingeladen werden, das ist der absolute Irrsinn.
Die JS-Welt geht da schon sehr weit,
was möglichst viele
kleine Dependencies für wirklich alles
Anlegen angeht.
Ja. Aber die Idee per se
finde ich nicht falsch.
Irgendwann geht es halt bloß gefühlt ein bisschen kaputt.
Also das hat halt, das
löst halt auch einen Haufen Probleme,
die da halt irgendwie zum Beispiel bei
C++ oder bei T, ist ja so,
dass das dann alles zu einem Binary zusammengelinkt werden muss,
das heißt, es dürfen keine doppelten Symbole
oder
unterschiedliche Symbole auftreten.
Das führt dann dazu, dass du eigentlich nur eine
Version von irgendeiner Dependency
haben darfst.
Und das müssen sich halt alle einigen.
Das führt dann ganz oft dazu, wenn du
einen komplizierten Dependency-Bomb hast,
dass es einfach keine bei dir der Auflösung gibt.
Und dann geht es einfach nicht.
Es müsste, dass wenn
dein Conan und dein Compiler
sich auf irgendwas einigen, dass du dann über das
Mangling unterschiedliche Versionen
von deinen Libraries
ranlegen könntest, oder?
Das geht theoretisch. Und das kann man auch manuell
Da kannst du unterschiedliche Versionen
von einer Dependency
hart rein kompilieren.
Und der löst dann halt intern auf,
dass die sich nicht überschneiden.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon manuell gemacht.
Also Dinge dann einfach noch mal in den extra Namespace gekippt.
Der mangelt einfach diese Bude dann anders,
damit das dann hinhaut.
Ja, es sind dann eigentlich andere Typen.
Also er ändert quasi die Namen der Typen,
dass er dann wieder hinhaut.
Ja, also wie genau das bei Rust funktioniert,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Also bei C++ hast du halt Name-Mangeling,
ich hätte jetzt überlegt, dass man das Feature nutzen könnte,
um dafür zu sorgen, dass es keine Namespace-Clashes gibt,
wenn du unterschiedliche Sachen hast.
Also ähnlich stelle ich mir das, bei Rust ist es halt so,
dass deine YAML-Parser-Version 3 und YAML-Parser-Version 4
unterschiedliche Module sind, die du dann unterschiedlich verwenden kannst.
Genau, bei C++ hast du halt das Ding,
dass dieses Binary-Interface, was dann am Ende rauskommt,
dass das standardisiert einem bestimmten Standard entsprechen muss.
es ist halt nicht nur ein Standard, weil es halt auch
Plattform-unabhängig ist, also es gibt die Microsoft
Namingling und
alle anderen.
Und bei Rust
ist es doch gar nicht standardisiert, die nehmen sich das
die
lassen sich das verlassen.
Genau, die sagen einfach,
verlasst euch mal bitte nicht drauf.
Was ja insofern okay ist,
als dass es noch keine alternative Implementierung
dieses Compilers gibt, sobald es dann
mehrere Versionen, mehrere
Implementierungen von Rust gibt, hast du dann ein Problem.
was allerdings eher so ein ungünstiger
Fall von
C++ ist, dass es irgendwie fünf
Implementierungen gibt, die alle immer noch am Leben sind
und es irgendwie eine
zentrale Stelle geben würde, ich meine, es gibt ja auch bloß
einen Standard-Committee, die einfach
bloß einen Compiler bauen würden, der für alle
Plattformen die Features unterstützen würde,
dann könnte man auch häufiger mal einfach die Version
aktualisieren, weil alle
der einzige Grund, warum du keine
aktuelle C++-Version
überall hast, ist, dass du irgendwo an irgendwelchen
Stellen noch Compiler verwendest, die
dieses Feature, was du nutzen möchtest, noch nicht implementiert haben.
Und dementsprechend kannst du nicht nachziehen.
Andererseits ist es halt cool, weil
wenn du nur eine Implementierung von irgendwas hast,
dann hast du keinen vernünftigen Standard.
Den Standard, der ist ja erst nur dann
ausgereift, wenn du irgendwie zwei, drei
verschiedene Leute, die unabhängig voneinander
probieren, das zu implementieren,
sodass du eigentlich dann die ganzen
Wachstern findest.
Also ich sehe das auch positiv.
Ja, wo die Frage ist, den Standard brauchst du
halt nur dann, wenn es mehrere Implementierungen
davon gibt.
aber ja
es ist aber auch immer schön
sondern implizit, so Teil der Implementierung
ist eigentlich der Standard
es ist nicht spezifiziert, aber so wie
das implementiert ist von dem einen, der es bis jetzt
gemacht hat, müssen es halt dann alle, die
hinterherziehen, auch machen. Der Standard ist halt schön
wenn du wirklich gucken willst, ist das jetzt ein Bug
oder ist das ein Feature, was ich jetzt hier
gefunden habe. Also es ist eine
gute Art der Dokumentation, weil es halt wirklich sehr
genau beschreibt, wie Dinge funktionieren
Lest du manchmal C++ Standard?
Ich lese öfter mal C++ Standard, ja
also einerseits um irgendwie
also bei Stack Overflow wird das relativ viel zitiert
da gibt es auch diese Standard Lawyers
die irgendwie das
übermäßig gerne machen, aber es ist auch
wirklich hilfreich, wenn du mal
irgendwas Spezielles hast, zu gucken
Apropos Standards und
bekannte Compiler-Implementationen
habt ihr schon mal was mit D gemacht?
der Sprache D
die seit gestern mit in
GTC aufgenommen wurde
die D wurde in GTC aufgenommen
Ja, vorgestern, gestern. Wir haben übrigens heute
22. Juni, um ein bisschen zeitlichen Kontext
zu schaffen. Ich dachte, wir wollten nicht mehr das
Datum der Shows haben. Das sind die letzten drei
Folgen jedes Mal gemacht. Das kann man auch durchziehen.
Ich habe damit noch gar nichts
gemacht. Ich habe ja wirklich so ein Faible
für esoterische Programmissprachen, aber das ist
irgendwie komplett an mir vorbeigegangen. Aber so richtig
esoterisch ist D, glaube ich, nicht. Also wenn du dir das
als C++-Entwickler anguckst, wirst du da denken,
ach, das ist
ja, das ist halt fast das Gleiche.
Dies und jenes haben sich halt ein bisschen
Breaking verändert.
oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung von D. Ich weiß, dass es existiert
und dass es Leute nutzen.
Es ist einer der
Advocators von D.
ist alles,
da heißt er Dimitri Alexandrescu.
Also einer von den ganz großen
Zyplusbus-Gurus ist auch einer der
Hauptentwickler und
Advocates von D.
Im Endeffekt ist D, wenn ich mir das
syntaktisch angeguckt habe, ich lege mich jetzt hier weit aus dem Fenster,
ich habe da wirklich eine Zeile geschrieben, ich habe mir ein paar
Beispiele angeguckt, sieht halt doll
C++, an manchen Stellen
ein bisschen hübscher,
dass du dir denkst, ja, das ist von Leuten
gemacht, die halt 4C++ machen
und die ein paar Pain-Points, die sie hatten,
gefixt haben.
Einen Pain-Point haben sie insofern gefixt,
dass sie
Garbage-Collection mit eingebaut haben in die Sprache.
Angeblich optionale
Garbage-Collection, das hat allerdings
bis zur letzten Version gedauert,
bis auch die Standard-Bibliothek ohne Garbage-Collection
funktioniert hat.
Und was an D noch ziemlich geil sein soll, ist deren Metaprogramming-Modell.
Aber da ich in kaum irgendeiner Programmiersprache wirklich Metaprogramming-Modelle verstehe,
halte ich jetzt immer die Schnauze.
Also zumindest Makros und sowas, was jetzt in C++ Kunst-Expo heißt,
ist wohl in D schon relativ lange etabliert.
Was das auf jeden Fall hat als Feature, was ich total toll finde,
ist, dass es wohl nahtlos C und C++ auch als Bibliotheken,
also C- und C++-Code einbinden kann und damit interagieren kann.
Die haben halt nicht Mühe gegeben,
auch das Name-Mangling da direkt in ihren Compeller einzubauen,
dass es identisch ist.
Genau.
Aber ich meine, C++ ist halt aus den frühen 80er Jahren.
Und allein schon, wenn man Dinge, die heutzutage moderne Sprachen,
einfach Kleinigkeiten nimmt und die in C++ einbauen würde,
wäre das auch schon toll.
So etwas wie, mache Dinge standardmäßig Kunst.
Und nur wenn sie nicht konstant sind, musst du es ranschreiben.
Oder nimm, hab nicht Struct und Class als zwei Dinge, die irgendwie ähnlich benutzbar sind,
aber dann trotzdem irgendwie auseinanderfallen, wenn du einmal das eine benutzt und einmal das andere.
Oder solche Sachen, also einfach Sachen, die historisch gewachsen sind.
Da hat, glaube ich, so eine Sprache generell, eine neue Sprache einen übelsten Vorteil,
weil sie halt nicht diesen ganzen Craft von den letzten Jahrzehnten mit sich rumschleppen muss.
Standing on the shoulders of giants.
Wenn man es gelernt hat, wie man Sprachen entwickelt,
dann geht es natürlich ein bisschen besser, angenehmer.
Es kommt halt immer dazu, dass du möchtest,
dass dein Code, den du einmal geschrieben hast,
in Zukunft auch noch weiterhin kombiniert.
Und das ist was, was du in C++ nur ganz schwer hinkriegst,
wenn du versuchen möchtest, Sachen zu deprecaten.
Also wenn du sowas einführen möchtest wie Variablen,
sind per default const oder immutable.
Und erst wenn ich ranschreibe, nicht mehr Kunst,
kann ich so erwähnen, das würde halt sofort alles kaputt machen,
was da draußen existiert.
Wenn du allerdings sagen würdest,
ich habe unterschiedliche Versionen dieser Sprache,
damit kompiliere ich unterschiedliche Compiling-Units
und linke die dann hinterher aneinander.
Und zur Compile-Zeit haben unterschiedliche Regeln
für diese unterschiedlichen Code-Parts gelten,
dann könnte man das eventuell machen.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sowas in C++ vorgesehen ist.
Ich habe jetzt einen neuen Podcast entdeckt
die sind fast noch
unprofessioneller als wir
die haben eine Webseite, keine Webseite ist
sondern die haben ein GitHub-Profil
sie haben noch kein Logo
und die Audioqualität der Aufnahme ist auch relativ schlecht
weil drei Leute am Telefon sind und
es klingen alle wie Telefonqualität gefühlt
der heißt
Call for Explanation
das ist quasi von
Rust-Core-Leuten, wo sie über
RFCs der Sprachen reden
und da sind auch so Sachen
eingefallen wie, wir haben ja dieses Problem, dass wir
beim Matchen von Sachen, also Matchen ist
wie das Switch-Keyword bei Rust,
da ist unser
Pattern-Matching ein bisschen komisch, da musst du plötzlich, wenn du
Sachen, die hier Referenzen enthalten,
matchen möchtest, musst du plötzlich
dieses komische Rev-Keyword einnehmen.
Wir würden jetzt gerne mal ein RFC machen,
wo du dieses Rev-Keyword rausnehmen,
wo du es weglassen kannst.
Das führt halt nur dazu, dass Code, der vorher nicht
kompiliert hat, plötzlich kompiliert und die Sprache ein bisschen
nachvollziehbar war und der Compiler macht für dich
bisschen mehr die Referencing als vorher.
Dann haben sie noch über andere Sachen nachgedacht,
die sie gerne ändern würden, so das Verhalten
von Lambdas in der Sprache und haben irgendwann festgestellt,
hm, das können wir leider nicht ändern,
weil dann ändert sich wirklich die Semantik der Sprache,
wir sind uns nicht ganz sicher, aber es könnte Leute da draußen
geben, deren Code nur funktioniert und
sicher ist, weil diese Regeln gelten
wenn nicht bestimmte,
es ging glaube ich darum,
wann eine Variable
in den Scope eines
Lambdas reingemucht wird
und wenn sie das gemacht haben, ist sie natürlich am Ende
dieser Variable weg.
Am Ende dieses Lambda
ist es weg. Und wenn du das Lambda
in einen Thread movst und das, was
du da reinmovst, in dieses
Lambda, so etwas wie
Mutex ist und du plötzlich die Regeln änderst,
dass das Mutex länger lebt
als vorher, dann
kannst du plötzlich wirklich Race Conditions haben,
die du vorher nicht hattest.
Was ist jetzt die Überlegung von Leuten,
die Rust entwickeln, die eine relativ
junge Neusprache haben, die jetzt schon
drüber nachdenken, irgendwann mal Zeugs zu
deprecaten. Da ist der Ansatz bei uns
ist die Compiling Unit, ist ein Crate,
ein Modul oder eine Library
und die
haben vor, wenn es irgendwann mal Rust
2.0 gibt, das wirklich so zu machen, dass du
unterschiedliche
Crates mit unterschiedlichen
Rust-Standard-Versionen
kompilieren kannst. Das heißt, du stellst den Modus um
auf einmal
1.18, was gerade aktuell ist
und die andere Library
populierst du mit 2.0 und kannst dir aber hinterher
trotzdem zusammen linken und weiter verwendet.
Dadurch kannst du deine Sprache modernisieren,
musst aber alte Libraries
nicht ständig mitziehen oder
anpassen oder deprecaten.
Das macht Swift übrigens gerade.
Ich wollte gerade fragen.
Mit dem Swift 4
haben wir ein paar Dinge wieder geändert,
ein paar Kleinigkeiten, es gab wohl keine Source-Breaking-Changes,
aber ein paar Updates gibt es
natürlich auf jeden Fall.
Und weil die Swift 2 auf 3
Migration unglaublich schmerzhaft
für viele Leute war,
also wirklich,
das war aber auch nicht gerade einfach,
gerade für eine große Codebase,
haben sich jetzt ein bisschen da Mühe reingesteckt
und der aktuelle Compiler kann sowohl
Swift 4 als auch Swift 3.2
kompilieren. Das ist jetzt erstmalig
der Fall, dass ein Compiler zwei unterschiedliche
Swift-Standards abkann. Vorher brauchst du zwei
Compilers dafür. Und du kannst
es jetzt vor allem modulbasiert rüberziehen
und du kannst deine einzelnen Module einzeln
auf Swift 4 migrieren und die
lassen sich nach wie vor gegeneinander linken
und dein Zeug läuft einfach. Das finde ich ein sehr
willkommenes Add-on.
Ja, wäre schön, wenn die das in Zukunft weiter
fürführen, sehr wahrscheinlich, aber
ich würde gerne aber auch mehr Breaking Changes
in der Sprache noch sehen. Von denen haben
ich jetzt versucht, dich ein bisschen zu verabschieden.
Du musst dann wirklich
den Hardstain Contract haben,
dass wenn du die neuen Features haben möchtest,
dann musst du auf die alten Features
verzichten und musst
wirklich den neuen Dialekt komplett verwenden.
Zwischen 4 und 3 und 2 gab es
wie gesagt, keine Source-Breaking-Changes.
Das heißt, dein Swift...
Okay, nee, fast keine.
Die Module, die du gegen
Swift 3.2
kopierst, müssen dann halt auch die alte
Standard-Bibliothek verwenden.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Spannend.
Das klingt nicht falsch,
aber das wäre ja trotzdem kaputt.
Das heißt, du musst für beide Versionen
immer die Standard-Bibliothek dabei haben,
zwei Versionen der Standardbibliothek. In Zukunft
vielleicht für jede neue Version
eine neue Version der Standardbibliothek. Ich habe neulich
so einen CppCast, das ist so ein C++
Podcast mit Bjarne Strustrup,
also dem Erfinder von C++ gehört
und die haben ihn ganz am Ende gefragt,
was er Leuten empfehlen würde, die ihre
eigene Programmiersprache entwickeln und er hat gesagt, don't.
Weil entweder
mit ganz, ganz großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit wird es nichts
und ansonsten hat man es
20, 30 Jahre an der Backe.
Achso, er spricht das
Und muss immer noch
die ganzen schrecklichen Entscheidungen
von damals ausbaden und
da drum rumwerkeln,
weil Leute immer noch ihren alten Code kompilieren.
Oh, schön.
Er bereut ja jetzt schon Entscheidungen,
also er hat relativ früh Entscheidungen,
die das ISO-Standards-Comitee
getroffen hat,
oder Entscheidungen, die er getroffen hat,
relativ am Anfang,
weil er schnell was fertig haben musste,
bereut. Er hat es schon mehrere Wochen
später bereut.
Und 30 Jahre später gibt es diese Sprachfischung.
Deswegen, wenn du eine Sprache entwickelst,
ja, mach es nicht.
Es gibt Hochschulkurse,
wo du deine eigene Programmiersprache entwickeln musst.
Da sollte es natürlich nicht wirklich daran arbeiten,
die zur Produktionsreife zu heben.
Aber wenn sich manchmal jemand hinsetzt,
so große Entities mit viel Manpower
und vor allem mit viel sehr gebildeten Leuten,
sowas wie Mozilla oder Apple,
Die können gerne mal ihre eigene Programmiersprache entwickeln.
Da kommt meistens was Gutes raus.
Aber du solltest ja von Anfang an drüber nachdenken,
was ist meine Exit-Strategy für Designentscheidungen.
Wenn ich mich jetzt für was festlege,
wie mache ich das nicht in fünf Jahren, wenn ich das bereue,
immer noch machen muss.
Also brauchst du selbst für eine Programmiersprache
Deprecation-Policies.
Das hat Zinklusbus halt leider nicht.
Das ist das Hauptproblem.
Gibt es noch was mit Go?
Go ist einfach noch nicht alt genug, um
dieses Problem zu haben.
Aber Go ist älter als Rust?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, Rust ist älter.
Es ist länger stabiler als Rust.
Das auf jeden Fall, ja.
Aber bei Go wird jetzt auch ziemlich viel um die
2.0
gemunkelt und es ist aber
noch nicht so richtig klar, was dann überhaupt da drin ist
und nicht drin ist. Die Leute wünschen sich
ja total Generics.
also so wie in Java
bei Go ist es irgendwie abstruserweise
so, dass man, wenn man
wirklich eine generische Bibliothek, die auf mehreren
Typen operiert,
machen möchte, dann hat man eigentlich nur die Wahl
also man
kann Interfaces nehmen, das ist
klar, aber wenn irgendwas nicht auf Interfaces passt
dann kann man
Dinge auf so ein leeres
Interface kasten und dann verliert man jegliche
Typsystem, genau, dann ist das Typsystem
komplett weg, weil jeder
jeder Typ implementiert
das leere Interface.
Da muss man es halt manuell zurechtkasten.
Oder sich sowas wie
algebraische Datentypen selber bauen,
indem man halt irgendwie noch einen Text dazu macht.
Algebraische Datentypen sind eine Droge.
Wenn du das einmal in der Sprache gesehen hast,
möchtest du es überall wieder.
Ich habe übrigens mal ganz kurz live Feedback nachgeschaut.
Go ist laut First Appearance
laut Wikipedia wenige Monate älter als Rust.
Bei Rust steht leider kein Monat.
Bei Rust steht nur 2010.
Bei Go ist es November 2009.
Ja, seitdem.
Aber stabil ist
das Go schon seit mehreren,
seit fünf oder sechs Jahren.
Das sagt Wikipedia leider nicht. Da steht nur das letzte
Stable-Release und das ist bei Go 26
Tage her, bei Rust 13 Tage.
Toll.
Ich weiß bloß, dass
Rust seine Design-Erscheinung
grundlegend verändert hat, nachdem sie gesehen haben,
dass es sowas wie Go gibt und dass sie eigentlich die gleiche
Kerbe schlagen. Deswegen gibt es jetzt in Rust
überhaupt sowas wie
wie Betriebssystem Threads
und kein Garbage Collection,
sondern ein Ownership und Borrowing System.
Sonst wären die beiden Sprachen wahrscheinlich fast gleich.
Sie haben quasi einen reichten Pivot gehabt
und eine eigene Nische dann gesucht.
Genau, also die wollten beide die gleichen Probleme lösen
und haben beide damit angefangen,
das über Garbage Collection zum Beispiel erstmal zu machen.
Lustigerweise war es ja bei Go auch so,
dass es eigentlich als Replacement für C und C++ gedacht war.
Dass aber jetzt die meisten Go-Programmierer,
also die machen auch immer so eine Community-Survey,
und die meisten Go-Programmierer,
die kommen wirklich aus der Python- und Ruby-Ecke zu der Sprache
und freuen sich, dass es halt irgendwie kompiliert und schnell läuft
und ein sinnvolles Typ-System hat,
was eigentlich auch zur Compile-Zeit relativ viel abhängt.
Die Leute, die, oh, es gibt sowas wie Typen,
irgendwann entdecken, oh, das ist ja cool,
das ist ja praktisch und nett.
Da fällt ja immer wieder dieses Zitat von Rob Pike ein,
der Go-Core-Maintainer bzw. Entwickler,
der mal rausgehauen hat,
dass das Zielpublikum von Go,
das sind Googler und keine Researcher,
die typischerweise ziemlich jung sind,
gerade aus der Schule raus,
wahrscheinlich Java gelernt,
vielleicht C oder C++,
vielleicht Python.
Und they're not capable of understanding a brilliant language.
Das ist so unglaublich condescending, dieses Zitat.
Es ist derselbe Typ, den ich vorhin erwähnt hatte,
der gemeint hatte,
dass es halt super chemisch ist, sowas wie Syntax-Highlighting
zu verwenden. Ach, das ist auch Warpike.
Kein teuerter Mensch.
Ja, also
ich stehe da so ein bisschen kontrovers
hingegenüber, weil einerseits hat er recht,
weil es ist halt wirklich
schön, wenn eine Programmiersprache schnell zu erlernen
ist und wenn sie relativ
einfach ist. Der Teil ist auch nicht falsch,
das sehe ich ein, ja. Und bei Ghost ist es
wirklich so, das macht relativ schnell richtig
Spaß. Gerade weil sie halt
neu
angefangen haben und einfach gelernt
haben aus den letzten
20, 30 Jahren Fehler in Programmiersprachen.
Go-Lernen geht echt schnell.
Man hat am Wochenende mal die Sonntag angeschaut und dann
kann man quasi jeglichen
Go-Code lesen. Das ist
echt cool, das sehe ich ein. Und sie haben auch
Vererbung weggelassen zum Beispiel,
was ich total toll finde.
Aber das haben alle modernen Programmiersprachen.
Genau, das sind halt so die Dinge, die alle modernen Programmiersprachen
machen. Aber das ist gut so. Auf der anderen Seite
stößt du halt wirklich schnell an die
Grenzen der Sprache
und wünschst dir eigentlich Dinge, die
abstrakter sind
und die ein bisschen generischer
und die einfach
ein höheres Abstraktionsniveau bieten.
Wenn es jetzt mit Rust vergleicht,
das ist genau andersrum.
Da hast du eine unglaublich brutale
Lernkurve.
Aber das ist so, dass es auf jeden Fall
erst wirklich viel, viel später anfängt,
richtig Spaß zu machen.
Und dann aber wirklich,
dann bist du auch da drin
und dann wird es auch nichts anderes mehr.
Aber das ist halt irgendwie
Oder Haskell ist auch so.
Das ist auch irgendwie so eine brutale,
abstrakte
Schmiede.
Ich laufe manchmal noch drauf los
und ich laufe immer noch gegen die Lernkurve
und stoße mir den Kopf so steil.
Genau.
Weil die Syntax so absurd anders ist.
Das ist ein anderes Paradigm.
Genau, aber irgendwann hast du es verstanden
und dann fehlt es dir,
wenn du es nicht hast.
Da fehlen dir manche Sachen, wenn du sie nicht hast.
Vorbei, wenn du jetzt C++ schreibst,
dann kannst du halt auch ganz schön viel aus Rust mitnehmen
in die Art und Weise, wie du C++ schreibst.
Hattest du nicht mal einen Vortrag irgendwo eingereicht?
Ja, ich hatte einen Talk auf dem Rust-Fest eingereicht dieses Jahr in Kiew,
aber der wurde leider nicht angenommen.
Da wollte ich so ein bisschen C++ und Rust vergleichen
und so ein bisschen auf die lustige Art und Weise
den Rust-Programmierer in C++ anbringen.
anhand der, es gibt so einen ganz
tollen Blogpost von dem
Osloer Tesla Club,
wo die einen Review machen,
oder Stockholmer Tesla Club,
wo die einen Review machen von dem Benzinauto.
Das liest sich, das ist sehr
lustig geschrieben, weil die das dann so
beschreiben, wie sie das anmachen und es macht komische
Geräusche.
Und dann fährt es aber doch irgendwie los und
es stottert aber und da muss man irgendwie so
ein Pedal drücken, das irgendwie
in Gang rein und raus geht und
total seltsam.
Man muss Flüssigkeit reinkippen. Genau, man muss Flüssigkeit
reinkippen, damit das losfährt.
Aber das ist nicht so, dass es irgendwie dadurch
nass wird, sondern das braucht es zum Fahren.
Flüssigkeit zum Fahren.
Aber das ist auch wirklich, es gibt,
wie heißt dieses Paradigm,
was Programmiersprachen angeht?
Du denkst dir eine Programmiersprache
XY aus. Ich glaube, das hieß nach dieser XY
Programmiersprache, die ich mir dementsprechend
nicht gemerkt habe, weil es ein komischer Name war.
Im Endeffekt ist, du hast
einen Erwartungswert,
was eine Programmiersprache kann, was du damit machen kannst,
was die alles abdeckt.
Alles, was weniger Features hat als deine Programmiersprache,
denkst du, das ist halt nicht mächtig.
Kannst du nicht die Sache machen, wie du die willst.
Fuck, Zypus hat keine Algebraischen Datentypen.
Mist.
Alle Features, die oberhalb von deiner
Erwartungsprogrammiersprache sind,
denkst du, das ist ein Kiki-Fax.
Ich kann mit meiner Programmiersprache gar nicht alles machen.
Kurz brauche ich
sowas wie Pattern-Matching
auf Funktionsebene
oder Garbage-Collection
oder wozu brauche ich, keine Ahnung.
Und das ist halt der Paradigm, mit dem viele Leute
an andere Programmiersprachen reingehen. Entweder sind sie
condescending, weil sie Sprachen weniger machen,
sie sind trotzdem Turing vollständig, aber du kannst
halt bestimmte Ausdrücke damit nicht
machen. Und bei Sprachen, die natürlich
sich ein bisschen weiter aus dem Fenster lehnen, einen Schritt nach vorne machen
und auch mal was Geileres
mal geiler sind, denken sich die Leute,
ich kann auch mit der Sprache, mit der ich kann,
mit der ich arbeite, die diese Features nicht hat,
genauso gut arbeiten. Wozu brauche ich das?
Deswegen
entwickeln wir uns nicht weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube so die ganzen C und C++-Programmierer,
die wären schon echt froh, wenn sie keine SecFaults und UserAfterFree
und den Link-Pointer mehr hätten, weil das mag keiner.
Da sagt auch keiner, das ist schon okay, das funktioniert ja trotzdem irgendwie.
Aber wenn du manchmal jemandem sagst, so etwas wie ein monadischer Rückgabewert,
so ein Result-Typ oder so ein Optional, das wäre jetzt schon schön.
Oder Algebra-Dargin-Typen, das wäre jetzt auch schon ganz nett,
weil da könnte man so Sachen schachteln und
Composite-Strukturen besser mit darstellen.
Ach, das geht doch so und so auch.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle mal in die Show Notes mit einem Link werfen
von einer Kurzgeschichte.
The Story of Mel.
Ein Programmierer der alten
Zeit von Vor-Compilern
und Mel didn't approve of Compilers.
Mel hat alles
selbst schön in Hand in Assembler geschrieben.
Das ist auch Quatsch.
Irgendwie so ein Programm sagen, was für dich automatisch
Code schreibt. Ja eben, schaffst du einfach selbst
bei Hand. Was soll denn das?
Aber ich liebe diese Geschichte einfach.
Ich referenziere die oft und gerne und die muss in die Show Notes machen.
Ich schmeiße es mal unter den Link, den ich gerade in die Show Notes geschmissen habe,
den ich noch nicht erwähnt habe.
Und zwar ist das auch, glaube ich, erst vor ein paar Tagen rausgekommen.
A Rust View on Effective Modern C++.
Das ist übrigens dieses Buch, was ich dir hier mitgebracht habe.
24 Specific Ways to Improve Your C++ 11 and 14.
42 Specific Ways.
42.
Im Endeffekt, ganz viele von den Regeln machen nicht das,
sonst ist es schlimm.
Und der ist aber relativ,
der Typ, der diesen Artikel geschrieben hat,
hat einen sehr guten
tiefen Einblick in C++, aber auch einen
ziemlich tiefen Einblick in die Interne von Rast
und vergleicht die miteinander,
sodass es für Leute, die aus beiden Ecken kommen,
sehr interessant ist. Ich habe das gestern Abend durchgelesen
und habe mir gedacht, das habe ich mal
wieder über beide Sprachen was gelernt.
Sehr gut lest man.
Und in die Ecke wollte auch dein Vortrag gehen,
bei dem wir dich jetzt gerade schon wieder abgewirkt haben.
Rust is a
Rust is a love letter to C++
Also ich möchte dich bitte darum bitten,
diesen Vortrag nochmal beim Rustfest
in Zürich einzureichen.
Da würde ich ihn sehr gerne hören.
Du darfst ihn auch sehr gerne bei unserem Lied abprobehalten.
Ja, das Gute an Vorträgen,
die man noch nicht gehalten hat, ist ja auch,
man kann sie immer mal wieder einreichen
und irgendwann wird es schon mal durchkommen.
Das ist halt bei den Was-Konferenzen gerade noch so ein bisschen das Problem,
dass die meisten Leute, die da hingehen, das auf eigene Tasche machen.
Und dass deswegen auch die Konferenzen nicht so super lang sind
und nicht so viele Tracks haben,
weil halt auch die Community noch relativ klein ist.
Jetzt im Vergleich zu...
Das machen halt Hobbyisten, da stecken noch nicht so viele Firmen dahinter.
Genau, und deswegen hatten die jetzt beim Rust-Fest in Kiew zum Beispiel
nur acht Slots, glaube ich, für Talks.
Die hatten auch nur einen Track.
Genau, nur einen Track.
Das heißt, die hatten aber irgendwie 60 Einreichungen oder so,
da müssen die halt schon gucken, was sie nehmen.
Wir haben ein paar Sponsoren.
Das sind zwar immer wieder die gleichen Bekannten,
die drei Firmen, die du alle schon kennst,
die alles was mit Rust machen,
aber es taucht immer wieder eine neue hier und da auf.
Ja, aber da ist für so einen lustigen C++ Rust Comparison Vortrag
auch kein, also finde ich auch voll okay,
dass sie sagen, wir konzentrieren uns mal auf das,
was den Leuten jetzt hier wirklich viel bringt.
Da waren aber auch so Vorträge dabei, wie
guck mal, ich habe im Spielen was geschrieben, so und so habe ich das gemacht.
Das ist
ja, das war jetzt
fachlich für Leute, die sich so einen Konferenztalk
angucken, vielleicht nicht so spannend, eher für
absolute Einsteiger.
War das der mit dem Snake's Tale-Spiel?
Ich fand es unglaublich spannend, wie der
das gepackaged hat
für verschiedene Plattformen.
Ist er eine komplett wasgeschriebene App für iOS oder Android?
Nee, das war ein anderes Spiel.
Ja, also wenn du natürlich eine größere Konferenz hast,
dann kannst du auch so Vorträge halten wie Postmodern C++.
Habe ich auch schon in die Showlands getan.
Das war das, was wir da vorne erwähnt hatten.
Sehr witzig, auch übertragbar auf andere Sprachen.
Kurz Meta, wir sind übrigens bei knapp zwei Stunden.
Ja, ich hätte noch einen GitHub-Star anzubringen,
Das war vom Entwickler
Burn Sushi auf GitHub.
Ich vergesse mal, wie er heißt.
Burn Sushi ist der
Andrew Gallant,
ist der Entwickler von RipGrab
und der in Rust geschriebenen
Recax-Implementierung,
die RipGrab so schnell macht.
Von dem ist jetzt ein kleines Tool,
was auch für andere Leute interessant ist.
Das heißt RootCD.
Das ist noch nicht mal fertig,
aber ich habe es schon gefunden,
weil ich dem Typen auf GitHub folge.
WooCity ist ein Kommandozahlen-Tool, was dir
den Unicode-Standard
durchsuchbar macht.
Das heißt, du kannst da einfach
offline drin nach Doc suchen
und dann prittet ihr dir alle
Doc-Emojis aus auf der Kommandozahlen.
Das ist eine kleine Spaß-Implementierung davon.
Aber wenn du es als Library in deine Anwendung
einbaust, könntest du damit einen kleinen Ersetzer
für Sachen machen,
der Begriffe
durch Emojis ersetzt.
Es ist mir deshalb
bloß in Erinnerung geblieben, weil ich es gebaut hatte
und es plötzlich nach dem Release-Bild
50%
größer war als der Debug-Bild.
Okay.
Wie fährt sich das?
Und zum Schluss kam raus, dass er
in seiner Config
einfach unter
Profile Release Debug
gleich True drin stehen hatte. Das heißt, er hat
alle Optimierungen, alles Inlining
und Outrolling gemacht, was
ging, hat aber trotzdem
den Code hinterher nicht optimiert.
und
Debug-Symote drin gelassen.
Dadurch wurde der Debug-Bild
15 Megabyte und der Release-Bild
20 Megabyte groß gewesen.
15 MB
oder 15 bis 20 MB
ist schon ein dickes Ding.
Ja, so eine Anwendung, die ich baue,
die irgendwie gefühlt 50 Abhängigkeiten
hat, die ist im Release-Bild
45 Megabyte groß.
Das ist nämlich was Go-Verhältnisse.
Naja, klar, es gibt
einen Artikel, der hieß, warum sind
Why are Rust-Binaries so large?
Das kam halt raus, das Fazit
davon ist, im Endeffekt geht es daran,
dass wir unsere gesamten externen Dependencies
statisch reinkompinieren, reinlinken.
Und wenn du das gleich mit C
machen würdest, wären die Binarys da genauso groß.
Unser Standard-Business ist mit drin, die liegt nicht
irgendwie unter deinem User-Lib-Verzeichnis.
Okay.
Exzent.
Und das ist alles mit da drin.
Wenn du die allerdings nimmst,
diese Debug-Binary,
die dann 40 MB groß ist,
und die als Release baust, ist sie dann nur noch
20 Megabyte groß. Wenn du die dann
stripst und alle Strings, die du nicht brauchst, rausschmeißt,
dann ist sie nur noch 10 Megabyte
groß. Und wenn du sie dann mit
UPX komprimierst, dann ist sie nur noch 4 Megabyte
groß. Und dann hast du auf den Zehntel
ihrer ursprünglichen Größe runtergekriegt und sie hat
die gleichen Funktionsumfang vorher. Also einen großen
C++ Codebasis kann auch mal
Gigabyte Debug Bineries rausfallen.
Wenn die komplett statisch gelingt werden,
das ist eine relativ normale
Sache. Also jetzt nicht so super mega
groß, jetzt nicht irgendwie
Microsoft
Millionen, hunderte Millionen
Seilencode groß, sondern einfach irgendwie so
zwei, drei, vier Millionen Seilen
Code-Bases, wenn du vier Templates nimmst.
Praktisch dann zwar manchmal, wie es zum Kunden ausgeliefert
wird, was das für Schritte durchwandert,
um dann in einen
übersichtlichen 50 Megabyte Download zu
passen. Das hatte mich bei meinem
witzigen kleinen Schwall-Projekt mal
angenervt, als ich versucht hatte, an dem
Swift-Source ein bisschen umzubasteln und die Syntax
zu ändern, und zwar als Deutsche zu übersetzen.
Das hatten wir schon mal thematisiert kurz,
dass ich
das C++-Projekt, was der Swift-Compiler ist,
oder die Swift-Sanit-Library,
die ist ja nicht in den
C++-Compiler selbst,
geklont habe, die Dependency mit runtergezogen
habe, versucht das Ding zu bauen
und der Debug-Bild einfach mal
mindestens eine Stunde lief, zwischen eine Stunde und
eineinhalb Stunden, das hat mich schon genervt, aber als dann
nach dem zweiten Bildversuch
mein MacBook meinte, oh, die Startup-Disc
ist voll,
das hat so 25 GB an Artifacts irgendwo erzeugt.
Oh, gut.
Das macht es etwas schwierig damit, es zu hantieren.
Das lasse ich mal sein.
Das ist gar nicht so ungewöhnlich.
Krass.
Ein Kollege von mir hat sein 256 GB MacBook
gegen ein 500 GB MacBook eingetauscht.
Und allein, weil er nach dem Komponieren ständig seine Festplatte freifatzen musste
von solchen Bildartefakten.
Dann hast du unterschiedliche Versionen von Sachen, von Dependencies, die du reinziehst.
Das ist schon unwahrscheinlich groß, das stimmt.
Ich habe mir hier neulich mal diese Xcode 9 Beta auf deinen Hinweischen runtergeladen.
Das ist ja auch ein Download von so 5 GB gewesen.
Die Beta sind immer noch ein bisschen größer, die haben auch die Wax mit drin, so weit ich weiß.
Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel Visual Studio
auf Windows installiere,
ist die Installation auch
5 bis 6 GB groß.
Das sind dicke Teile, stimmt.
Software ist dick und groß.
Aber sie muss nicht so dick sein.
Aber immer noch nicht so groß
wie Note Modules.
Genau, immer noch nicht so groß wie Note Modules.
Ich glaube, ihr seid da
geschädigt, was das angeht.
Da gab es noch dieses
Vergleich,
Neutron Star
und wie die Visualisierung
von Gravitation, wie irgendwas
dieses Sheet
in den Space reindrückt, wie irgendwas
den Raum krümmt, dass da Neutron Star
so eine Delle und dann hast du ein schwarzes Loch
und eine ganz tiefe Delle und dann hast du Node-Modules
und das geht halt aus dem Bildrahmen raus.
Da gab es immer so einen schönen
Blogpost, I peeked into my Node-Modules
directory and you won't believe what happened next.
So schön clickbait
formuliert und der hat, ich dachte einfach,
das war ein kompletter Witz, aber das ist ja
gar nicht mal so
falsch, dass zum Beispiel
das Package Babel
ein Bild von Guy Fieri
included. The fuck,
dieses Bild. Babel ist wirklich fast überall drin.
Aber was soll denn das?
Was ist das für ein schrotten Haufen?
So Beispiele von Bullshit, die da halt drin sind.
Wer ist nochmal Guy Fieri?
Dieser Typ mit den komischen Haarfarben.
Okay. Also ich weiß, dass irgendeine
Anwendung, die einen fancy Namen
hatte und in irgendeiner Stelle den Namen
mal erklärt haben, wo er halt
die gesamte Oxford-Vectioner als Dependency
reingezogen hat, damit sie irgendwo
Lookup auf ihren eigenen Namen machen können.
Das ist halt sowas, was
Jan auch noch gemacht hat
zusätzlich, das ist über deine Dependency
drübergegangen und hat Zeugs rausgeschmissen,
wo es davon ausgeging, dass du es nicht brauchst,
irgendwelche Assets, irgendwelche Dokumentationsgeschichten.
Ja, das war ausgefunden.
Das ist durchgegangen,
das ist nicht Teil des Sources, das ist nicht von deinem
Root-Datei aus erreichbar
gewesen oder sowas.
Ich habe es weggeschmissen. Ich habe natürlich schon beim ersten
Versuch irgendwie irgendeinen Fall produziert,
wo das hinterher dann halt kaputt war, was ich da
benutzen wollte und das Datei nicht mehr gefunden hat.
Ich habe es übrigens auch in Ihrem Blog-Kongebiet genannt. Ich sehe es gerade
aus dem Augenblick.
Glimmer brings in the entirety of Encyclopedia Britannica
just to display the definition for the word
Glimmer in its help menu.
Ja, genau.
Also nicht nur das Oxford-Dictionary,
sondern die Encyclopedia Britannica.
Das geht mir zu beidem.
Ja, du hast halt auch leider
in deinen Package-Dateien
kein Ignore-Feld.
Also bei Tommel-Dateien kannst du
irgendwie reinschreiben, bitte
beim Packagen schmeiß mal diese, diese, diese
Datei raus oder inklude nur diese Dateien,
wenn du irgendwelche Assets hast.
Das gibt es bei Node.js nicht wirklich.
Es gibt eine NPM-Ignore-Datei,
Aber das wird auch nicht von jedem gelesen.
Deswegen ist ja sowas wie Webpack jetzt erfolgreich.
Das macht das alles
nochmal ein bisschen gründlicher. Trotzdem hast du da, wenn du
nicht aufpasst, wenn du zum Beispiel
mit dem Electron Packager
eine Anwendung packagst,
hast du halt von den vorherigen Durchgängen
auch noch die anderen Electron Packages
mit drin liegen, wenn du es baust.
Da hast du ein Root-Verzeichnis,
da hast du ein Bild, wo deine
Electron Packages reinkommen.
Wenn du das nicht löscht, ist es im nächsten
Electron Package auch mit drin.
Oh Gott.
Ich habe mich gewundert, warum die bei dir im Durchlauf
500 Megabyte größer wurden.
Ein interessantes Problem,
worüber ich jetzt noch
mit Node.js gestoßen bin, ist,
dass es in Windows
ein hartes Limit gibt
von 256 Zeichen
für Pfade.
Und das scheint
irgendwie nicht die präferierte Entwicklungsumgebung
für Node-Entwickler zu sein.
Deswegen wird das nicht so super durchsupported.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es
GitHub-Issue, wo sich ganz viele Leute
darüber beschweren, dass es nicht geht.
Einfach NPM-Install geht nicht
und das liegt dann daran, dass
ihr Pfad, wo ihr Projekt drin liegt,
so lang ist, dass die 256
Zeichen nicht mehr ausreichen für die
Node-Modules und allem,
was da drin ist.
Das sind teilweise
Ordner in Ordner in Ordner in Ordner.
Genau, was ja eigentlich ein
komplett vernünftiges Ding ist in dem
Filesystem.
Da gibt es halt richtige Probleme
und es gibt keinen Fix dafür.
Du musst einfach dann
dir einen kurzen Ordner
am U-Direktorier von deinem Laufwerk
anlegen, damit das dann funktioniert.
Der Fix dann, der Workaround nutzt Jahren,
dass das dann wegfällt.
Das ist mir gestern erst passiert, als ich ein Backup
wiederherstellen wollte auf Windows.
Da habe ich halt irgendwas in den Unterordner
kopieren wollen und da kam es irgendwann nach 10 Minuten,
als er dann mit dem Kopieren halb fertig war,
kam dann,
dieser Pfadname ist zu lang,
bitte kopier es woanders hin.
Es wäre jetzt natürlich cool, wenn man bei Node, das würde wahrscheinlich
das Problem schon so ein bisschen lindern,
anstatt Node-Modules
den Ordner namens N oder sowas an.
Genau, da hätte man schon wieder
8 Zeichen gewonnen oder so.
Pro Ebene.
Was ja dann 35 Ebenen sein können.
Da steht dann in dem gleichen Pfad 35 Mal
Node-Modules drin.
Gott.
Das ist irgendwie lustig.
Man fühlt sich da so ein bisschen, wenn man das dann debuggt
und das dann irgendwie fixen will, dann fühlt man sich
so ein bisschen wie damals
zu SMS-Zeiten, als man noch irgendwie
probierguckt hat, was kann ich denn jetzt noch hier
weglöschen, damit das in die...
Also ohne jetzt, um jetzt noch Windows
noch ein ganz kleinen bisschen Bonuspunkt zu geben,
es gibt auch Fahrtnamen in Windows und Fahrtstandards,
die die längere
Fahrer erlauben, aber
das Problem ist die Windows-Zeiten noch nicht.
Oder NPM nicht.
Was heißt Fahrtstandard? Auf welcher Basis
läuft das dann?
Vermutlich auch ein Seminar-Teilsystem.
Haben die da ein anderes Format?
Genau.
Die haben, ich kann das mal recherchieren
für die Show Notes, aber das sind nicht die
normalen Partner, haben C-Doppelpunkt, Backslash
und dann geht's los, sondern da schreibt man
noch andere Dinge davor.
Ich glaube, dass es da noch verschiedene Standards für gibt.
Ich habe zum Beispiel manchmal so etwas wie
C-Doppelpunkt-Fragezeichen-Slash.
Ich habe noch nicht verstanden, was das heißt.
Also wenn irgendein Hörer
das kennt, dann schreibt uns mal bitte Feedback.
Ah, nicht C-Doppelpunkt-Slash,
C-Doppelpunkt-Backslash.
Das ist mittlerweile für Windows transparent.
Was?
Ja.
Wow, wie cool.
Das heißt UNC, Universal Naming Convention.
Universal Naming Convention Pfade in Windows.
Krass.
Die sehen aber nicht so aus, wie man normalerweise seine Windows-Pfade angibt.
Aber die können dann auch länger sein.
Vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal so einen Windows-Experten ändern.
das nämlich ein total
so in Nerdkreisen eigentlich
ja schon so ein bisschen unsexy ist, aber doch
ein ganz, ein sehr
weites Feld, ein sehr weites Feld, wo
Windows auskennt, ist mittlerweile so ein bisschen wie sich mit
Vortran auskennt. Es gibt tonnenweise
Nerds draußen, die ganz, ganz viel können, die aber alle
nicht bei ihren Eltern den Windows-Rechner
richtig einrichten können, weil sie es den ganzen Tag
selber nicht benutzen.
Ja, aber also auch so Windows-Entwicklungen
und so, das ist schon,
also ich denke immer von mir, ich kenne mich so ein bisschen aus
mit Computern, aber das ist halt wirklich so
ein komplett
eine schwarze Ecke, wo ich
wirklich gar nicht
großes Wissen davon habe, außer halt damals
irgendwie um bei meiner Mama
den
Virus runter zu hauen
oder um irgendwie so Standard-Admin-Sachen
auf einem Desktop-Rechner zu machen, aber
die Leute, die sich da wirklich auskennen, die
haben nochmal so ein komplett
obskures Nischenwissen, was total interessant ist,
wenn man sich das anhört, aber eigentlich
mehr so aus so einem morbiden Interesse heraus.
Das klingt wie so ein Dirty Pleasure von dir.
Genau.
Und manchmal, wenn mir danach ist,
dann programmiere ich gegen die Windows-Standard-Bibliothek.
Ich meine, ein bisschen auf Downtime habe,
dann eine WPF-App raus.
Der Steiger kennt sich übrigens auch mit Windows aus.
Vielleicht sollte ich ihn nicht diffamieren jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit,
aber der Steiger kennt sich auch mit Windows aus.
Dann lagen wir dir noch das nächste Mal als Windows-Experten ein.
Krass Zeug.
Nee, wollen wir mal langsam zum Ende für die heutige Folge kommen.
Also, rappen wir es ab.
Das war Folge 7 von Akronymisierbar.
Heute mit Special Guest Jupp.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Wo findet man dich online?
Ich gebe es auf Twitter.
Twitter slash Jupp0R
Ich habe auch einen Blog.
Jupp.ninja
Super Domain.
ansonsten findet man mich
in der Inf manchmal, im ASCII,
aber nicht so oft.
Oder der Kommentarspalte bei Akronymisierma.
Welche Kommentarspalte?
Die wir bis Folge 8 vielleicht haben.
Na, tschau.
Also, vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt
bis zu diesem Punkt.
Gebt uns Feedback über,
vornehmlich Twitter bitte,
das ist das Einzige,
wo wir wirklich dauerhafte Präsenz haben bislang.
Schreibt uns mal eine Rezension
auf Apple Podcasts
wie da eine ausschaut
wenn wir irgendwo mal eine bekommen
Genau, empfehlt uns weiter
korrigiert uns
auf freundliche Art und Weise
wenn wir Schluss erzählt haben in dieser Folge
und die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher beginnt
in 3